it's one of the most ridiculous videos
i've ever seen
but um not the only ridiculous video
i've ever seen just more ridiculous than
the video before it
is a video of a man with a bicycle and a
garbage bag in a walgreens in san
francisco and he's shoveling things off
the shelf
into the bag then he jumps on his bike
in the store
and just rides away security guard just
films him and then tries to grab the bag
and
isn't successful and this is what's
happening in san francisco the
shoplifting has gotten so bad
17 different walgreens stores have shut
down cvs and walgreens
representatives apparently said it's
like the hub for organized retail crime
and uh like i said it's not the first
time there's another video from i think
was last year of women in the cosmetic
section just shoveling things into bags
and there's a story from the new york
times from a couple weeks ago one of
their writers said when he moved to san
francisco
he goes to a walgreens and sees people
just walk in and start grabbing things
and walking out the door without paying
and he was confused like wait what's
happening it was so brazen then he
walked into a safeway and people are
grabbing wine and just walking out and
it turns out
i guess the way san fran sees it
paying is optional they are so overrun
with crime cops just don't bother
anymore and this is what's happening in
big cities
with another more serious story out of i
believe it's atlanta
where there was a a drive-by shooting
and the cops just do nothing
they don't pursue the shooters they just
just stand around and then eventually
render aid
people are kind of mad why aren't you
responding well we're not allowed to
anymore
so this is what's happening in a bunch
of other places we're hearing that
police aren't responding to 9-1-1 calls
anymore and from this
quality of life is dropping in many big
cities and of course people are fleeing
well i guess the good news is the more
conservative people from these cities
will leave
and then maybe help make redder areas
redder or whatever
but the problem is actually that
liberals are leaving the places where
they voted in these politicians and then
they're moving to the red areas and
voting in
those same politicians so we gotta talk
about of course we'll talk about that
we'll talk about the fbi
and and uh the binding administration's
plan to target
white supremacy because apparently
that's that's the the big issue
i guess so uh well joining me today to
talk about these topics we have emma joe
morris
do you want to briefly introduce
yourself my name is emma joe morris i'm
deputy politics editor at the new york
post
uh before that i was in tv i've been
working there for a little bit over a
year
and that's kind of it right on you expo
you you published that big hunter biden
story i guess right
it was joint multiple effort it was
no well it was uh it was a low-key move
a couple months ago but
yeah that's that is part of my career i
can take credit for that that's right
we also have libby evans how's it going
i'm editor-in-chief with the
post-millennial
right on welcome back do you want to
just thanks is that a good enough intro
for
are you happy with that yeah that's
pretty much what i'm doing i'm also i'm
also working on a book
about how to make a conservative arts
movement and that's coming out with a
bombardier press in the fall cool i'm
excited about that
i'm excited about it too it's gonna be
awesome yeah and then of course
come on i wanted to really say thank you
to the viewer who said last night
no need to puke it's luke i really
appreciate that
i'm getting a lot of fanfare for being a
simple humble t-shirt vendor which you
could find out more by going to the
shirts dot bestpoliticalshirts.com and i
might start a cult on luke uncensored
dot com so i have that going for me what
is this shirt you're wearing uh today
i'm wearing just
two weeks to flatten the curve with uh
dr fauci
and our lord and savior bill gates that
is always right no matter what
the youtube moderating police should
love this t-shirt as of course i am
praising
the true words that were issued last
year plus some months that
still do my my favorite thing about bill
gates is that he's not a doctor he's i
think he's a farmer
officially like if you know that's
that's what he does he is the largest
farmland owner in all of the united
states and surprisingly has a lot of
influence and a lot of money carefully
crafting a pr image of himself that yet
still hasn't been able to scrub the
connections with jeffrey epstein
i just i just love like joe rogan can
come out and make a comment about
vaccines and get the meat everyone in
the media is going nuts and screaming
how dare you and then bill gates comes
out and he gives advice and they're like
we love you bill gates and
constantly talks to dr fauci as we found
out through the fouchy emails there was
constant communication between the two
setting up the policy for the united
states which i think there is a lot of
criticism to be had
for right on so yeah like the definition
of oligarchy basically
pretty much yeah yeah i think that's
what's wrong with san francisco to be
honest it's massive
wealth disparity so there's all these
poor people and they're just taking
whatever they want no one can do
anything about it
but we're going to talk about all that
before we do we have an amazing sponsor
my friends
go to strongerbonesandlife.com
and you can get this ageless
multi-collagen from biotrust
51 off you want to know why you need
this because i i say this all the time i
know how old you all are watching this
show and
it's at the point where you got to take
care of your joints your hair your skin
your nails
so you know that i skate i get uh my
knees are all busted up i've been
skateboarding for a couple decades and
whenever i whenever i
literally crouch down you can hear it
it's so loud everyone in the room can
hear it
yeah i probably need this so i'm really
grateful that biotrust is sponsoring the
show but in all seriousness
it's a it's legit it's it's what you
need for your bones your skin
uh if you're a guy you want to exercise
you want to take care of your joints
what you got to do and if you're a
lovely lady worried about your skin or a
man what about your skin you know
no no gender stereotypes here then go to
strongerbonesandlife.com
and pick up your angels multi collagen
we got some things to tell you you've
got a 60-day money-back guarantee
the healthy aging support of collagen in
its ideal form
the five key types of collagen you need
from four different sources
hydrolyzed collagen peptides meaning
better and faster digestibility
support maximum benefits for every order
today biotrust will donate a nutritious
meal to a hungry child in your honor
through their partnership with no kid
hungry.org to date biotrust has provided
over 4.4 million meals to hungry kids
please help biotrust hit their goal of 5
million meals this year
is non-gmo it is free of artificial
colors flavors preservatives and
sweeteners
and free of gluten antibiotics and rbgh
and rbst
no odor or taste unlike bone broth and
other collagen supplements
no clumping unlike other supplements
free shipping with every order and this
one's really cool
free vip live health and fitness
coaching from biotrust's team of expert
nutrition and health coaches for life
with every order plus
you'll get their free new e-report the
14 foods for amazing skin with every
order
biotrust thank you so much for being a
sponsor of the show again stronger bones
and life link
in the description below let's uh and
don't forget i actually have a big
announcement for everybody who may have
missed it we talked about this yesterday
go to timcast.com become a member we'll
have a bonus segment coming up later
tonight after this show
and uh you'll get access to the members
only area
you may have noticed if you are a member
there's a weird formatting thing
happening where
articles are starting to appear in the
members only section you see that's
kind of bad news but actually it's
really good news
the bad news is we we knew there were
going to be some formatting issues
because the site
is currently undergoing a complete
redesign you can still find all the
members only segments when you click it
it'll just
ask you to sign in but you may notice
that many of these articles are actually
news articles because we are officially
getting the ball rolling on the newsroom
and that means cassandra fairbanks is
officially on as editor-in-chief
i know this triggered many on the left
they're freaking out they're furious
they're outraged but her articles are
very straightforward
very professional and whatever their
opinion is on her opinions the articles
are fantastic
so we're actually going to be using i
think we have one two of these articles
pulled up we'll be talking about today
but this is all possible thanks to you
we were able to get cassandra
as the editor-in-chief she's we're going
to be hiring a bunch of people
there's going to be an independent fact
checker so anybody who's concerned about
any kind of bias from any of our
reporters we're going to have someone
totally offside a different place who's
going to read through and independently
fact check and again
that's with your support as members at
timcast.com now let's jump over to that
first
story the amazing viral video market
watch reports walgreens shoplifter fills
trash bag with stolen goods and bikes
out of store
bay area retail theft has seen walgreens
close
17 san francisco stores in the last five
years look at this amazing photograph
for those that are just listening i'll
describe it there's a woman
and she's like exasperated with her hand
up as a security guard is literally just
filming the guy
and the dude's stuffing what looks like
what's like a 25 gallon shopping
garbage bag he's just dumping things off
the wall i wonder what he's stealing
what are they like they're like the eye
care aisle i think personal goods
personal usually what's behind that
little wall what do you mean personal
goods
like uh deodorant deodorant this dude is
stealing all the deodorant
i don't know that he's stealing all
deodorant but then he just hops on his
bike and rides away and that's it
that's it that's what's been happening
in in in san francisco
so apparently there was this uh
proposition back in 2014
that was pushed obviously by the
democrat super majority that would make
any shoplifting under 950 a misdemeanor
and at that point cops were like well
you know we're not going to respond to
these calls anymore
once the cops stop responding more and
more people start committing these
crimes
more people committing crimes means the
cops can't respond to everybody so now
it's just
it's a riot like literally i would
describe this as san francisco
is in a permanent state of rioting it's
a permanent state of shoplifting for
sure
but but or looting we'll call it looting
i think it is that and it's because
the police officers obviously aren't
going to
prosecute these misdemeanor crimes
there's nothing
for them to go pick these people up
and also people are just going to get
released as soon as they're arrested
anyway
so even if they were to arrest people
for these misdemeanors
the da's just gonna let them go it's
completely pointless policing
would you want to live there you know i
would not
in fact don't you live in new york i do
but new york is different
although i will say that uh the last
time i went to rite aid and i tried to
pick up some gum it was in a locked box
and i had to take it
with gum gum gum it was like a it was a
four pack you know
so that's serious money right but i had
to take it up to the front to get it uh
released from the locked
from the locked box another thing that's
really incredible here
really stupid is that a lot of these
stores are closing down
in droves i'm i'm hearing estimates of
17 dwayne reeds being closed in
california because of the constant
theft because walgreens in san francisco
specifically yeah
they can't make any money because people
are just coming in taking whatever they
want and then
the security guard i mean that was the
most hilarious part of the the video
that not many people picked up because
it was it was saw
it was so awesome to see the security
guard's literally standing there like
and then the lady next to him was like
hey should we call 9-1-1 and the
security guard
is like no no i stand the security guard
security guards getting paid what like
10 bucks an hour
the cops don't support the stores
anymore the laws that have been passed
are just it's happening every day
i'm i'm with the security guard in this
one i'd be like
yeah right back in i think what was it
1998
i was working at a hat shop in
philadelphia uh
i don't even know if there's hat shops
anymore but i was working there and
there used to be this guy who would come
in every couple of days
and steal a stack of hats and it was
just me at the store
a stack like a full ass like stack of
hats
and he'd walk into the store and i'd be
like hello again how are you
and he's you know i'm gonna take these
hats
okay yeah he'd be like i'm gonna take
these hats i was i don't know i was 20 i
don't know
no wait don't yeah and i was like okay
well when you take the hats i'm gonna
call the police and he's like yes i know
you're going to call the police
he walked out of the store with the hats
i called the police
two hours later they show up i'm already
closing the store i file the report
i was walking home from work one of the
days and there he was
on the street with a blanket laid out
with all the hats and i was like hey
how's it going he was like how'd that
work out for you
oh that's amazing yeah and that was that
he should have at least given you one of
the first
you know he really should have my boss
who was this woman who was kind of
badass she was like you have to go after
that guy and i was like
nah nah i'm not doing that i can't
believe i can't possibly do that i'm 20
i'm high like i'm not add add four
dollars an hour and we'll attack on
security
maybe yeah i mean i was working at
sunglass at university
and i mean we used to get robbed
constantly but they told us like that
was a policy it's like you don't
go after the thieves i mean especially
in san francisco like
you don't know if they have weapons are
you really gonna like the security guard
how much is he getting paid 20 bucks an
hour he's gonna
risk getting stabbed or whatever for
deodorant is that what you said yeah
yeah
there is zero incentive for the cops and
even less for the security guard well
so think about this problem i mean how
do you how do you how do you solve it
then
right i think i think it's i think it's
you're right
the guy's stealing much of deodorant why
should i care
however if you don't stop this guy what
happens
everyone starts doing it it's a
permanent state of looting well and
that's what's going on and this was a
terrible law it should never have been
passed i think that's clear
and it also laws like this i think it
was what like prop 47 or something
like this are completely they go against
what the liberals are trying to do
anyway
because once you have all of these
places shutting down
you're recreating the food deserts that
so many city policies we're trying to
avoid so who's going to open a grocery
store in an area with high crime and
then the people who live in that area
aren't going to have any food
and then you're going to have a food
desert and then you're going to have an
obesity problem and it's just going to
compound
actually one of the things i was reading
about when the walgreens started
shutting down
elderly people who live in san francisco
can't get their medications anymore
because there was there was one story
about a guy who used to walk downstairs
and then walk 10 feet to the i think it
was like a duane reader or whatever cvs
they closed down because of all the
shoplifting now he's got to walk miles
like one or two miles
to actually get to his pharmacy now and
it's only a matter of time before they
all shut down
you know my favorite thing about all
this though is one of the remedies
to all the shoplifting has been they
started putting the items that are
getting stolen in lock boxes
like my gum okay well what happened was
the item so there's a there's a photo
that went viral showing
uh like hair care products and the hair
care products for black people were in a
lock box
and the ones for white people weren't
and the left started saying it was
racist
and it was interesting because i'm sure
the manager and the corporation did not
go out there and say oh you know we're
going to do this because the company is
racist and lock up only the the ethnic
minority here
they're probably just looking at a list
of like things that were getting stolen
and said if it's getting stolen lock it
up
and some guy who has no idea what's
going on just goes okay product 17 and
product 34. now to stop the shoplifting
they're all racist i guess
the other thing too is that because so
many of these stores are just corporate
um chains you don't have anyone who's
working at the store who really cares
what goes on at the shop yeah it's not
like a local pharmacy that's run by a
family or whatever
who's going to actually care about what
happens there well
i think another aspect we're not really
considering here is maybe the guy
thought it was a
amazon cashless store it was just
walking out i mean that's also a
possibility here with his mask on but it
was it was a mask for kova he was just
trying to consider it but in
all seriousness i remember being in san
francisco two years ago investigating
the crime that has been happening there
and it's been slowly escalating ever
since i remember walking
and just talking about the poop on the
street which there's
an exorbitant amount of people literally
taking a crap in the middle
of downtown san francisco i remember
reporting on this walking by and there
was a woman
screaming on the top of her lungs
running across the street jaywalking
there's police officers behind me as i
was doing the walking talk
police officers heard this woman's
scream in the video
you can see this right now uh
youtube.comchain san francisco
and then the cops just decide to walk
the other way and i'm like
what the hell am i experiencing where
literally people are
some would say right now that they're
vaccinating themselves in the middle of
the streets
they're not doing that they're just
trying to be
wearing masks because i don't think i
don't think they're that available i
think they're injecting something else
into their veins into the middle
in the middle of the street but it was
it was like a zombie apocalypse
wasteland
two years ago and now to see this these
stories and see it escalate and to talk
to people who are there i mean
we're talking about the center of tech
entrepreneurs we're talking about
silicon valley we're talking about some
of the richest most influential people
in the world who voted for this now
having to deal with the ramifications of
this
here's the best part during the
lockdowns
all we couldn't go to the bars we
couldn't go to churches there was no
water cooler there was no conversation
you couldn't see your neighbors
if you were going to see anything in the
news it had to go through twitter and
facebook and youtube and whatever big
tech platform
if you wanted to buy a book it had to be
on amazon or you have to go to you know
probably just amazon to be honest and
these people from san francisco are
regulating the opinions on these
platforms
which means the world view that created
the nightmare dystopia that has san
francisco
it's being perpetuated through these
platforms even right now even with the
lockdowns being lifted and our ability
to
go out and see movies and talk and hang
out still for the most part
our opinions are sent through this
filter of the big tech oligarchs
you look at how they run where they live
their opinions should not be the ones
we're propping up
but that's exactly what's happening so
it's only a matter of time to be honest
well and these are also people who
didn't ever consider ethics they're only
considering
algorithms and things like that they've
never looked into
the actual effects of what they're doing
and nobody ever taught them how to do
any of that stuff because we completely
depleted our educational system
so that what do you do you major in
marketing and memes which
okay that's interesting i suppose but it
would help to have some measure of
philosophy
and understanding of political discourse
and perhaps history that isn't entirely
filtered through the lens of whether or
not it's racist
i i feel like a big component is it's it
well i'll put it this way it's funny
that there's some capitalist criticism
but then we also have this very
serious problem of critical race theory
ideology in our schools
you on one hand have college where it's
like a large component is ridiculous
jobs that
are just for making money but now
colleges are being taken over by really
ridiculous majors that have nothing to
do we'll never make money so it's you
can either have the one extreme of like
you said
you're studying memes because memes make
money for advertisers whatever or
critical race theory and you know gender
sciences and studies which don't produce
anything for society hey there's nothing
wrong with memes
okay i love the names beams are amazing
but but also
another thing we have to understand here
major you could actually get yeah
it's probably the most useful one that
you can actually get the best money for
your brand it's a component for
marketing
right but about a lot so we had a
problem for a while where a lot of jobs
we had were pointless
like the internet gets invented and then
i mean look no disrespect to my friends
who work at fast food but a lot of these
cashiers are being replaced by kiosks
well they're being replaced by kiosks in
part because the minimum wage is going
up to 15
an hour and mcdonald's for example
doesn't want any part of that so thanks
joe biden for eliminating a bunch of
entry-level jobs that could have taught
young people how to
have a job and show up on time there's
also the issue of
unfettered immigration creating
low-skill competition for those young
people
and then the young people actually don't
end up working these places anyway then
they're told by their parents to skip
these jobs and go straight to college
then they get indoctrinated with
ridiculous ideology and then they get
out and they're like
why can't i get a job in a newsroom with
a gender studies degree and it's like
because you're an idiot
did you see the thing now where um the
cbc
i don't know if you follow the canadian
broadcasting company but
they've decided to suspend all
commenting for articles on
facebook because they don't want their
reporters and journalists to feel bad
when there's negative feedback for their
stories
it's such the stupidest and most fake
argument cause i'll tell you this right
there's a bunch of stupid like
cringy leftists who are tweeting outrage
that cassandra has joined and she's
going to be running the newsroom
with that i don't care i'm like dude you
like you you guys
you'll literally get fired by your boss
in two seconds if you say like fart
you know what i mean you just went off
and were screaming at this ap reporter
who got fired for having bad opinions
and you know what i'll eat this one
i was actually saying well maybe ap
shouldn't hire her and now there's equal
criticism to me because cassandra
certainly got feisty opinions as well
all right so i'll walk maybe i'm wrong
maybe we just don't have
you know you have your reporters focus
on like if they're going to be
opinionated on one thing maybe they
should cover something else
so so i'll i'll take that criticism but
how are you going to come out
taylor lorenz who uh i i don't have the
biggest issue with
but i understand why people are upset
with her in the thing she posts for the
new york times
she's she complains all day and night
about journalists getting harassed and
how it's wrong
especially women journalists and now
what
i've got cassandra and she wrote she's
written five articles they're all very
straightforward regular news
and the left is screaming like it's the
apocalypse digging up her old tweets and
posting them and tweeting at me
i'm like is this a harassment campaign
because you know when you come out and
complain that we tweet at journalists
and then you tweet at me you think i'm
gonna have any sympathy for you not you
all are nuts all right well the thing is
it's not
the the thing on the left about
uplifting women and you know not
attacking or harassing women
that only stands for women that share
the same leftist ideology it doesn't
actually
mean that there's support for
conservative women emma joe i think that
you've probably seen this as well well
of course i mean i remember
like when we were doing the hunter stuff
you know we were talking about it and
and
i was thinking about you know obviously
what the backlash would be and
i was thinking about it and i you know
check all these boxes
for the people that kind of you know
come after you with the pitchforks
and and i was thinking okay i'll be home
free because
i'm exactly who they would want to
uplift you know and i'm breaking a story
and it's a big story
and i'm a young woman and uh you know
i'm an immigrant
and which story was it specifically just
for people who don't know
i broke the hunter biden laptop story um
that was my scoop and i went through the
laptop
and i wrote all the articles uh leading
up to the election that got the new york
post uh kicked off twitter and facebook
so i can i break the internet basically
i i can just imagine that all of the
democrats were cheering like here's a
prominent female journalist
proving that you know shattering the
glass ceiling i wasn't going that far i
wasn't going that far but i was thinking
that they wouldn't attack me personally
you know i obviously figured they would
go after the story but i figured that
i kind of fall into a lot of their
protected classes that you often see
and i wasn't expecting that the backlash
would be so personal because of that
oh dude these people man they're nasty
people but listen but you know
what you're saying about cassandra i
don't know about her opinions
or nor do i care because it shouldn't
really matter it should be about the
work that she does and what she produces
for you i would think and that was
something that came out from the whole
thing with
you know after we broke the internet and
after you know the new york times came
after me and
washington post and joy reid and npr and
whatever
you know all the polite people and uh
and the post didn't even wince you know
that not only were they expecting it and
not only did they not care
but they were just kind of looking at
the story on its merits and
uh whatever the people were looking at
on my instagram of
pictures from when i worked at fox you
know that was one thing that they were
pulling up that i'm a
you know trump apparatchik because i
used to work at fox and i had all these
pictures from when i
just got out of school i was like 23 and
i was meeting all these trump people who
were coming to fox and
taking pictures and posting them and
that was supposed to be proof that i was
like a political hack
and you know the employer didn't care
because at the end of the day it's like
what work are you doing and if we're
going to appease like a twitter mob that
you know
they come and go like the wind and it's
you can't you can't run a business that
way
and uh and that's why canceling trying
to cancel me personally
didn't work and that's why it won't work
consumption and it won't work with any
business that doesn't bend to it because
if you just don't care
it just passes like a storm right right
i think conservatives also need to stop
thinking that these people have
legitimate complaints
so for whatever reason
i think people on the right
anti-establishment
whatever you want to call it because
they're certainly liberals who are
anti-woke anti-establishment as well
although many of them are becoming
conservative they seem to think that
these people maybe are just misguided
and that if we just have a conversation
calmly and rationally they'll change
their minds
that's just absolutely not true it's
just just not the case
it is so divergent right now this the
the political factions in this country
there's a bunch of different ones
some are aligned with others but the gap
between
those people who are screaming at you
and calling you a russian agent or
whatever
and saying normal people there's no
bridge
there's no words you can say there's no
convincing them and and many of them
probably know they're they're nasty
evil disgusting vile people they they
they're trolls who go look at chrissy
tygan for instance right
tegan or whatever her name is she had
that tweet where this guy was begging
her please take down that fake post i
never said those words and she's like
too bad you're a racist and i'm gonna
watch you burn
they know they're evil they know it well
they think they're entitled because they
think that they're right
and they think that they're right
because they never examine their views
they don't examine the undercurrents
uh that are that are holding their
perspectives in place
and they would find that they're not
there i mean these liberal ideologies
are like shifting sands
you know you stand in one place and then
suddenly you're somewhere else
because nothing there's no stability
underneath these uh
there's no foundations to it so if we're
not consistently and constantly
examining our belief systems
to try and understand what we believe
and why
you know i say this all the time then we
then we have nothing and we have nothing
at all
i don't think it's a belief system i
wouldn't i no i don't think it's that
sincere
i think it's a it's like a character
it's a personality it's somebody who's
ready to take a bludgeon and hit
whoever's in front of them
um i mean come on this isn't like about
morality it's about it's about having
like chrissy teigen
it's about having the right to push
somebody around and get
praise for it um but like you said it's
like shifting sounds there's no
continuity there's
no like i think they just think there's
no
you don't think so i think they think
that they have a moral superiority about
it
i think that that's a shroud yeah that's
something that's used to like
get props for what they're doing but i
think underneath that
it's just more about control and
and i don't want to use the word yeah
it's about bullying i think arsonist
yeah yeah they they take pleasure and
destruction
so those uh uh those those direct
messages that got released
showing chrissy teigen's messages the
story i guess basically is this guy was
accused of being racist because someone
photoshopped him saying i guess the n
word
and he chrissy it's okay when you're
hunter biden though
right right right well so chrissy teigen
posts an image i guess on instagram or
something like that
he messages messages her saying please i
never said those things to fake
photo like this is this this is
destroying me and he was having suicidal
ideation
and she's just laughing she's like ha ha
ha i don't care
screw you you're racist you deserve it
but he didn't actually say those things
she doesn't care
she comes out later and admits yeah i
was a troll i was screwing with people
it is what it is
these are just evil people who enjoy
watching others suffer
i don't think it's even evil i think
it's like an insecure husk
you know like if you think about like
who does that it's people who
who need a source of like feeling good
about themselves that doesn't come from
anything other than kind of like
imposing
whatever they're doing and then getting
likes for it i mean watching someone
suffer and laughing about it
that's like that that feels evil to me
well a lot of this is the definition of
mirth
mirth is taking joy in someone else's
pain a lot of this is also surrounding
narcissism and ego
and what we were talking about earlier
these social media algorithms that
incentivize it
and and reward it if you look at what
gets promoted what gets talked about
what the algorithm pushes on the general
public it's usually
drama it's usually fighting it's usually
putting someone down and it's promoting
the larger divide and conquer agenda
that makes people want to attack each
other
and not really truly look at the true
cause of their problems in their lives
so i think you know there is an element
of evil you know cats torture animals
for some
for for some reason there is an element
of just that there is an element of
business incentive knowing that you're
going to get more followers more
retweets more likes if you
do start that drama and i think there's
also even a bigger agenda possibly even
above that
uh pushing people to hate each other and
fight each other
that also again psychologically people
are doing without even knowing that
they're doing it themselves
there's this viral thread from some like
crackpot guy who's like fascism is back
here's proof and it was the story about
ron desantis banning critical race
theory in florida
and then he just like creates this weird
version of reality where what rhonda
sanchez is doing is comparable to what
the nazis did i guess which makes no
sense and then he just like he's like
the nazis were banning
you know knowledge and books and this is
it it's happening and it's like bro
you guys have been banning books for
years like amazon literally bans was at
burning books
and and these people genuinely are
freaking out waving their arms and
they're screaming
that fascists are taking over it is kind
of funny when you think about
the right when they were like ah the
cultural marxists and the communists are
taking over
and it's like you know the thing is
there's an objective reality
and if you read cbs if you watch cbs and
fox news
you'll get a hard dose of reality and
say huh
i kind of understand what's what's
happening the thing is conservatives
according to at least one study i cite a
million in one time i've cited a million
one times
conservatives do read about a third of
their news from mainstream liberal
sources
moderates read about a third of their
news from conservative sources
liberals 95 to 100 of their news comes
from
liberal news sources that's exactly what
happens when i mean when i talk to
liberals
that i know the ones that are still
talking to me which are not that many
i'm mostly just in my family they don't
really have a choice but anyway
yeah they don't see the same news that i
see at all there's just no
there's nothing to connect it yeah
there's there's it's hard to watch
there was this guy who got uh he's like
a call of duty gamer i guess and someone
he tweeted about a video about something
political and he was like this is crazy
what's happening
someone said hey you should watch like
you should read glenn greenwald matt
tybee and watch tim cast
and then he said something like absurd
about me that was based on grifters who
will like pull clips from the show take
them out of context and repackage them
and there was a story about democrats
and segregation or something i can't
remember exactly which segment they were
talking about
but he said it's not true it's clearly a
line i won't even watch the video
and then i mentioned something about
democrats even at the federal level
signing on to about to repeal
uh uh the the anti-discrimination the ra
the anti-racial discrimination policies
from their constitution constitution
in california all of these democrats
like even at the national level were
saying to california like yes we agree
with you removing
your anti-discrimination provision in
your own constitution
so that they could implement racial
policies and universities
which is that we've seen segregated
dorms we've seen
uh race-based uh selection for for
schools
so that i always tell i always tell
people what what the democrats want to
do
with with universities is
there's a kid whose skin is too much of
one color and you know so they tell you
you can't go to the school you look too
much like those other people that's
literally what their plan is
this guy responds with well why haven't
i seen that story
you're not looking for it guy well if
all you're reading is fake
news yeah like at this point it is so
painfully obvious that the mainstream
media
is just like more than half lies i'm not
gonna say it's all lies
there's a lot of really basic stuff i
mean we're reading a lot of this news
right now clearly the video of the guy
shoplifting that story from market watch
is a real story you can watch the video
but when it comes to politics it's just
word vomit
they just make up trash well they are
making up trash and i think that
you mentioned desantis banning critical
race theory in schools
and that gets picked up by you know your
attacker joy reid and other people
by say you know and they're saying that
uh they're banning the
actual teaching that slavery existed and
you know and it's like
none of that is true and if you actually
look at the bills
that are that are coming up in these
legislatures uh they're saying things
like
you cannot teach that one race or
ethnicity is better than another
right right right you know it's like
doubling down on
actual uh anti-discrimination policy
and the thing too is critical you know
the another thing that's coming out now
is this idea that critical race theory
is not being taught and the left is like
no critical race theory isn't being
taught that's not what's going on
and no critical race theory is not being
taught it's being embedded in pedagogy
it's being completely
you know linked in with every aspect of
curriculum
so that you can't take it out it's not
that it's being taught it's being
indoctrinated there's a difference
but the thing that's such a troll now is
like nicole hannah jones or is that her
name
1619 yeah she's on twitter like this is
why
you know because it's starting to be
banned and that's
now proof that it's all true so so
but but uh you are completely right it's
indoctrination
and they're so if they want to teach
about
critical race theory great why are we
teaching fifth graders about an academic
college level
theory what they're actually doing is
teaching the ideology of it
but more importantly like you were
saying when they come out they're like
no one's teaching this
technically they're telling the truth
they are telling the truth there was
this really great meme image i saw
i didn't say it to me it went viral it
was an image from a workbook from a
grade school
you ever you know the old trope of the
school the school
math question a train leaves pittsburgh
traveling at 70 miles an hour
a train leaves cincinnati traveling at
40 miles an hour if they're just
if they're this far apart how long until
they crash or whatever
there was this problem that was getting
shared around and it said
it showed a picture of a white guy and a
black guy and it said
john is a white man who has been stopped
by the police three times in the past
year
harold is a black man who's been stopped
394 times if the difference is like
what's the percentage of times the black
man has been harassed by police
something like that like that's
indoctrination it sure is
totally unrelated things that are using
the the the cult ideology
in in just like you were mentioning
right
in math problems that are unrelated
that's how they get it they get it right
it's in math problems it's in art
classes it's in history
it's in literature it's in literally
every aspect of it
and when they're done with you know
embedding critical race theory and
everything
uh they're also and they're also pushing
in um climate alarmism as well
not to take anything away from climate
change being a thing
but teaching kids what opinions to have
before you give them facts
about what's going on is that's
indoctrination
when it comes to the climate change
stuff i think the global elites are
betting on winning
because they're buying beachfront
property so they're basically telling
everybody like hey if
all of you give up all of your luxuries
we'll save the world
by the beachfront in miami because their
bet is
if we make all the poor people own
nothing we get our private jets we get
our yachts we get our beachfront
property that's the plan baby
there was a hysterical thing that
happened yesterday where in new zealand
there's a
what is it schools schools climate
strike school strike for
climate it's like the greta thunder
thing and there's branches everywhere
so the auckland branch of the school
strikes for climate
decided that they were going to
completely disband they were formed in
2019
but there's too much systemic racism in
their group of eight to 18 year olds
so they've decided to completely disband
stop dealing with the climate thing at
all and
only uplift the uh black indigenous
people of color
who are working to do it so all the
white people are like you know what
we can't possibly do this work because
we're not you so y'all do this work
and we'll we'll pump you on social media
okay and that's how we know we're
anti-racist
that's amazing it's like we burned down
your neighborhood in riots
and we think you should rebuild it
because it's yours
it's yours you guys deal with it you
guys know better than us so
we're going to go sit over here we you
know
worthless white people we we got
problems man it's not even like
that's new zealand you said right yeah
well you know new zealand is a disaster
jacinda ardern with her like global
censoring the internet project that
she's trying to get everyone on board
with because of the christ church
we we are lucky that we have a
constitution in this country
otherwise we'd be dealing with the same
fate as canada which is just like a
randomly arresting people or the uk
what is the uk doing more lockdowns they
announced more lockdowns when their
debts have been going down and they're
extending it
was it like four years yeah they're at a
four-week low it continues to go down
but the uk government still is like well
we need to lock down more because of
this indian variant which again doesn't
correlate with the hospitalizations the
cases and the numbers
a lot of this is you know in my opinion
more about control
and when we look at the lockdowns when
we see the larger effects of them we
don't see any efficacy we don't see any
scientific data showing that they
actually helped especially with states
like florida and texas disproving a lot
of the big data
surrounding uh this particular case but
but
what did the lockdowns do they helped
out the billionaire class because the
billionaire class was allowed to be open
amazon walmart costco whatever other
special interest
business as usual you run a church you
run a business you're screwed
and then you know another thing that
happened there's this horrible video i
tweeted it out today
and and it's heartbreaking of a father
being arrested
in front of his children because he
practiced his religion in canada and
held religious services
and seeing videos like that infuriate me
because it also plays into what we were
talking about in the beginning of this
broadcast these huge
waves of violence that are taking over
major cities not just in san francisco
atlanta new york but hold on that point
you made about the guy getting arrested
remember when the when the pandemic
first started and we saw those videos
out of wuhan
where the chinese authorities were
dragging people out of their homes
and we were like wow china's crazy
and then it happened in canada like
hundreds of times
it even happened here in the u.s and
it's happening right now as we're
speaking
as a florida jewish community in new
york city yeah as florida's doing huge
open concerts 12 000 people at the
bitcoin conference
canada you can't even have a religious
service which is absolutely infuriating
and when police officers you know a lot
of their time
a lot of their resources were spent
directly at shutting down businesses
at shutting down church services and
they did it happily
and at the same time what did cities
like new york city do
they released violent criminals onto the
street the resources for the policing
went towards innocent people
innocent people were sent to jail were
were prosecuted were punished for doing
everyday average things and now the
united kingdom's saying we need more
lockdowns so what you're saying is what
you're saying is uh
abolish the police i i think there's a
discussion to be had
especially when it comes to policing and
i'm not afraid to say that i i think
that you know we definitely need to have
that conversation especially with what's
happening in atlanta
there was a drive-by shooting there's
videos of police officers standing by
and deciding not to intervene or do
anything because
the mayor banned them from even uh doing
pursuits
in the city of atlanta so there's a
report from michael tracy
about all of the ridiculous covid finds
that police were
were writing for regular people for this
for nonsense there was one story i think
was out in new york
a jewish guy he had his store was closed
but he opened
the door for fresh restaurants and then
the cop come or the
health and health official is like we're
gonna write you a fine and he's like why
i'm close
like doors open sorry it was interesting
a year ago
because the churches were all closed i
think it was in pittsburgh
a church group decided to hold their
service in walmart
yeah that's right that was amazing
it was so infuriating to watch as all of
the corporate like we were talking about
luke all the corporate
interests got to keep their businesses
open and the little shops close down in
my neighborhood like a ton of little
shops are gone
and it's it's sad to see the rite aid is
still there with the gum in cages
they got people to worship the lord in
walmart they sure did
that is okay i'm sorry man you you you
could not have written a future
nightmare dystopia that like
that bad what do you think because when
they were writing identity four they're
like well people are still like
practicing their religious ceremonies
you know in private
well not really 94 was like worship big
brother but at the very least
man we we could we could we could go for
an uh a a nightmare dystopia where
we go to the corporation for our
religious ceremonies because the only
place the government allows
it's like wally yeah that movie was so
prescient
yeah man i think you know honestly it's
uh it's it's
mike judge is a prophet yeah idiotic
that was amazing too idiocracy
did you ever see em forrester i mean
it's not a film but he wrote a book
called
the machine stops and it basically it
takes place in the future he wrote it in
what like i think 1911 1918 somewhere
around there
and everybody lives in their own little
box everyone lives in their own little
cube
they interact with each other through
what's called the machine they
deliver speeches to the machine they
react to each other's
lectures through the machine they ask
the machine to bring them things
the machine brings them you know someone
to sleep with
and then takes their children away and
puts them in a different little box the
earth is uninhabitable
and they don't know how to interact with
one another it's like being in a chicken
coop
it kind of is except it's also kind of
like coveted lockdowns
yeah man idiocracy so what so uh what we
have uh
donald trump as president he's literally
in the wwe hall of fame
he is he actually is yeah he actually is
the actual individual of donald trump
donald trump is in the wwe
hall of fame he was the president of the
united states and like camacho and
idiocracy he's like this wrestler
so not one for one but so much of that
seems to be coming true and it's it's
rather nightmarish
but you know it's not it's not
completely obviously the movie is very
different
but there's funny things to point out
about it i'll tell you what's really
disconcerting is
when you you look at
the policies coming from democrats the
ideology coming from the left
the things they believe like like which
one who i think libby you're mentioning
this it was a shifting center or was
that you emma like shifting sand beneath
them yeah
you're saying this they have no real
moral framework or foundation
it's just whatever is convenient for
them to own the cons
to gain some kind of victory there's no
morality there's no framework it is just
literally in my opinion is fire
our our country our culture is a is a
house made of brick and stone we've
built it over a long period of time
we got some weird rooms in this place
that's for sure
and then along comes new ideology that
just starts burning and destroying these
things
there's no real rhyme or reason to to
their ideologies other than
we're right and we want power but it's
just like one thing that's
i mean there's so much of this that you
could have never predicted i mean i
remember talking about some weird
virus that's going on in china in
january and seeing some weird videos and
oh but that you know won't actually come
you know they've had stars before and it
hasn't come
but yeah so you know there's been so
much that you really couldn't predict
standing here now a year ago but the
thing that i find really striking is
people's willingness to go along with
whatever i remember just like having my
jaw
drop hearing the stories and
understanding that wuhan was allowing
international flights but not domestic
flights in china
hearing that i was like wait what's
going on here i remember hearing about
the wuhan laboratory
you talked about it automatically cut on
youtube on twitter on facebook
uh just utterly deleted and and the
control of social media i think
you know you kind of talked about it a
little bit talking about how unethical
they are
and how uh you know they're just doing
things for
profit and i think that this deserves a
larger conversation because
they essentially are the ones that are
controlling communications
controlling so many important aspects of
our life that if
if it was free if information was
free-flowing we could have dealt with
this
in such a way better fashion
but we judge we judged our information
right we judged it through the lens
of ideology so instead of saying like
here's some information let's look at it
objectively let's measure it against
reality let's have you know let's
have an open discourse we measured it
against our concerns that
you know saying the virus was from china
was racist
we measured it not trump he called it
the kung flu well that was
and they told you to go to the chinese
day parade in new york city yeah i mean
you had bill de blasio and nancy pelosi
both saying come out to chinatown
stop being racist you had them saying
that trump was
overblowing the virus and then so
quickly thereafter saying that he wasn't
taking it seriously enough
and it turns out that i think hhs under
his
um under his leadership was dealing with
it in
january but we don't look at reality we
don't look at information objectively we
look at it through the lens of
you know our political priorities
and that's a real problem and that is a
problem of leadership specifically but
it's also a problem for us who keep
voting for these people
who don't have any concern other than
maintaining their own power base but i
even think that's like two meta
you know like human functioning and like
human cognition
has existed longer than like the
internet controlled our communication
and
people like you would think that there
would be some level of like functioning
and thinking that goes outside of the
prism that like big tech and the media
present information to like you know we
were talking about
how draconian it got and you know for
instance i
i got a trespassing ticket during covid
i well
trespassing trespassing um for playing
squash
in a park wow cause
you know in new york they closed
playgrounds and i needed to exercise
and i wasn't about to just run around in
a circle on a track i wanted to play
with the racket
so i hopped the fence to a squash court
and got caught by
so you're confessing right now oh oh
i've already i've already pleaded guilty
and paid my ticket so
i'm home free but no but you know i so i
got this ticket for trespassing playing
alone in a park
in a gated like space and i was nowhere
near anybody and there was no infection
that was happening at that moment
and i got and i was thinking about the
ticket and i'm like
is there not no capacity or for nuance
to distinguish between something that's
dangerous and harmful and something
that's not
like the the how reticent people are to
go along with something that makes
absolutely no sense for the sake of just
being like a
bot for for our like ruling class i
guess
it's just like that but we were talking
about kobe that was something and that
has nothing to do with the media or with
tech that has to do with your own
judgment
but it also has to do with how far you
have to be pushed in order to
fight back against something right most
people pretty much just want to live
peacefully they just want to
take their kids to school they want to
get dinner on the table they want to
relax on the weekend
and so until the point comes and we were
talking about this before until the
point comes when you can't get dinner on
the table
yeah and unless you're pushed past that
breaking point
what you're going to do is you're going
to do your job and you're going to get
dinner on the table and you're going to
try and take care of your kids and
that's what you're going to do
well i i'm i'm i'm uh i don't know what
the right word is
i'm skeptical that the same things that
led to say the arab spring or
traditional revolutions we've seen it
with food will have will have the same
role particularly because millennials
don't have kids
it's really really easy to feed one
person
but a lot of these revolutions it's
because food is coming too expensive why
well
people have children so when it comes to
the point where your kids are being
threatened
a person will go to great lengths to
protect their children
don't have any i mean well they do
obviously but they're disproportionately
less
they've got things like cockapoos and
yeah little little
little what are those little pomeranians
yeah pomeranians they look like happy
things
little yappy things it is uh i will say
though that the um
the stuff shortage in the u.s i think is
uh
getting worse my i only have one child
but my grocery bill keeps increasing by
something like 25 or 30 every every
couple of weeks
yeah that's crazy my normal grocery bill
for like you know your basic
trip to the grocery store a little bacon
a little pasta and some fruit whatever
who cares
this would be like 50 bucks and now i'm
up to like 125
for the same stuff we went to a local
grocery store
and i was just getting some basis i
can't remember what we were gonna make i
think we're doing like a taco night or
something and it was like 300
for not even that much meat sour cream
you know avocados and i was like this is
a mistake
and then i was like everything was just
it added up and i was like what
this is mind-blowing to me like how did
it get so expensive we didn't have a
full cart
i'm buying way less meat than i used to
it's not like i was buying that much of
it but now there's just like
one night i'll make my kids some poor
child there is
there is something interesting happening
though in terms of you you were talking
about like the indoctrination
about people just willing to go along
with whatever is being said something
interesting happened we have the story
from timcast.com jon stewart shocks
stephen colbert in rant about lab leak
being the most rational explanation for
kovid
i don't know if you guys saw this but
jon stewart appearing on the late show
with colbert
had colbert on on the defense colbert
trying to
stop jon stewart who was basically just
going off saying
he's like you come to me and tell me
there's a novel coronavirus that's
released
and you want to figure out where it came
from why don't we ask the lab that
literally works on the novel coronavirus
where it may have came from
and when you ask them hey where did this
come from they go maybe a bat
made it with a pangolin and you're and
this is john stewart
he gets up right into the camera colbert
desperately tries to make it seem
plausible that it wasn't china
this is what freaks me out a lot of
people have been saying like oh they
think we've been infiltrated by china
and their influence has taken over
mike pompeo said the chinese communist
party has infiltrated
every facet of government from city to
to local to state to federal government
and then you see this why is colbert so
desperate
he's like maybe the lab is there because
of all the bets bro there's no there's
no there's no bats there
they got the bats from hundreds of miles
away john stewart is right
now this is interesting i don't know if
jon stewart will actually be a wake-up
call for regular liberals
maybe but jon stewart is is interesting
he's like he was frozen in carbonite
almost he's like han solo of our
generation right
back when he was still on the show he
was honest he praised project veritas
for their reporting
he would he would criticize obama when
obama was deserving of criticism
but he was a liberal he was a democrat
guy not necessarily democrat guy but you
know liberal
he leaves now he's coming back in the
limelight with a twitter account
and all of a sudden the left is calling
him a republican
colbert says when did you start
interning for ron johnson
right that's creepy that's creepy level
tribalism that jon stewart doesn't exist
in
yeah it was interesting too because the
backlash on twitter was so
severe against jon stewart saying things
that are not only completely obvious but
have been obvious for a long time and
that the washington post recently had to
completely walk back
everything that they said about this the
the the lab leak theory
oh i'll be fair to washington post in
may of last year they ran an op-ed
talking about lab leak
however as soon as the republicans
started saying it tom cotton they were
like oh this is a conspiracy and y'all
are nuts
their take on today's issue was pretty
telling they wrote an article
an opinion piece that was titled jon
stewart's rant as a reminder
don't rely on celebrities for covid 19
theories
meanwhile this is the same media
publication that a few months ago
had a headline article saying dwayne the
rock johnson urges fans to wear masks
after he and his family get covered 19 a
real kick in the gut
i mean obviously these people don't have
any morals don't have any
objective stance on issues all of it a
lot of it is power a lot of it is ego
but but a lot of this is sociopathic
insane criminal behavior in my opinion
because what jon stewart said
made absolute sense he brought and
concluded facts that
people were talking about for a very
long time that have been censored
away from the general public and stephen
colbert i don't know what they did to
him but they did something
because if you remember his show even on
comedy central he was hinting and
pointing at issues that were pretty
poignant that were pretty
populous that were pretty important i
remember even talking to him
about bilderberg which he knew a lot of
things about extensively
and now he's literally doing commercials
for
big pharma promoting the vaccine there
in one of the clips i don't know
if it was yesterday or the day before
but he released a video of him dancing
around
with with singing vaccines telling you
how you need to take the coven 19
vaccine
because it is safe it is effective
johnson and johnson are our heroes
pfizer is going to help you
literally it's a sick disgusting clip of
him dancing around here's
and saying if you're one of my family
members you don't take this vaccine
you're not welcome to any of my events
it was it was repundant to say the least
but but this is a man that literally
just
it looked like he was doing a commercial
for pfizer look
it's it's it's weird how the left has
become instantly pro
big pharma when they're always very
critical of it they've been pro big
pharma for a while i think i mean you
can
see the establishment i guess yeah i
think they have been if you look at
go ahead oh i was going to say um when
it comes to
the vaccines the biggest issue i take
with celebrities giving medical advice
is that they're gonna write articles
saying don't do it right they're they're
saying oh john stewart exactly i don't
listen to celebrities
colbert's literally doing it i have a
friend who is dealing with nerve damage
because we what we think happened was he
was given bad medical
advice what i guess what they're saying
is that you you need a doctor to tell
you if you can get the vaccine
for most people there's no issues but if
you've had covid within a certain time
frame
there may be an adverse reaction don't
ask don't don't come to me for advice
i'm telling you a story about my friend
you talk to your doctor to get sound
medical advice right but i'll tell you
this
my my friend didn't get that advice he's
now learning about this after the fact
and he's dealing with nerve damage in
his arms and legs
i'm not trying to freak people out or
playing any conspiracy or anything
anything like that i'm just saying maybe
you shouldn't go to stephen colbert
or joe rogan for your medical advice
maybe if jon stewart wants to make a
political point about a lab in china has
nothing to do
with whether or not he's advising you to
take medication
they want to come out and claim that joe
rogan for for making his comments about
vaccines saying if you're young that's
what joe rogan said he said if you were
young you shouldn't get it
i don't think joe should be giving
advice definitely not i don't think dr
fauci should either
because regular people have very
specific medical needs their doctor
needs to inform thereof
inform them of so if colbert is going to
come out and do a commercial for big
pharma and vaccines it's on the same
level as joe rogan doing the same thing
you need to talk to a doctor and if you
don't like their opinion you get a
second opinion you get a third opinion
and i always tell people this make sure
you're not getting a political opinion
i think that's important and i but i do
think that the left has been
shilling for big pharma for quite a long
time they're very interested in
promoting all kinds of drugs and turning
children who are
gender dysphoric into lifelong medical
patients
this has been going on for quite a while
they were pushing the
um antidepressants for kids and pushing
the
you know focus medication for kids
they've been doing this for decades
how can how can anyone trust big pharma
after the opioid epidemic
that ripped through and destroyed middle
america that that is still causing
severe effects i mean
but it's not just the democrats it's
also the republicans i mean donald trump
wanted to call the coven 19 vaccine
the trump scene and he's the one that
authorized emergency
uh use of this he's the one that pushed
for this he's the one
that wanted you know to be congratulated
by pfizer
but you also had kamala harris and
andrew cuomo both saying in the fall
that
they were skeptical they were skeptical
of the vaccines and then as soon as joe
biden becomes president
it's you know everybody roll up your
sleeve can i just uh
read a story for you guys go for it this
is from the guardian friday
23 may 2003 bayer division knowingly
sold
hiv-infected protein yep so i i i'll put
it this way
look i'm not a doctor i don't have all
the answers
uh i can't tell you what to do that's
why i always say you gotta go to a
doctor there are a lot of people that
tell me like oh i don't trust my doctor
and i'm like dude if you don't trust
your doctor then i don't know who you
trust
like you go to a different doctor and
you don't trust them the fact is when i
go to the doctor and they prescribe me
some weird name i don't know what that
is i'll google it look it up because
ultimately you're responsible for your
own health
but we're talking about massive
multinational corporations and they're
more concerned with their bottom line
they don't exist to save you they exist
to make money and sell a product
when we can look at history and see
bayer knowingly sold
hiv infected protein i think it's fair
to say you're not you're allowed to be
skeptical of massive multinational
corporations
you should be skeptical of that of
course across the board no matter what
it is that they're selling
yeah well they're criminal institutions
if you look at some of the big pharma
agencies i don't even want to mention
because i don't want to get anyone in
trouble but if you look at some of the
big pharma agencies that are behind
some of the medical procedures here a
lot of them have been previously charged
with bribery
corruption have been heavily fined and
have been caught buying off
doctors to push for policies along with
politicians
that mainly benefited them and when you
look at i mean
a lot of people really do not understand
the severity
of the opioid epidemic and the level of
horrendous
horrible addictions that it caused all
throughout middle america and that story
is
under reported significantly because if
you even just drive around
you see entire cities with doctors that
were paid off
that absolutely ravaged and destroyed
them
from the from the very up i got i got to
read the story sorry i don't know an
interrupt but uh luke brought the story
before we started
from abc news 899 people got expired
vaccine doses at times square site
health officials say 899 people received
expired covenant 19 vaccine doses
okay they just repeat the headline but
anyways from the eights from abc news
reporting from the ap and that's
basically it they say atc vaccination
services the company that administered
the shots under contract to the city
said in a statement we apologize for the
inconvenience to those receiving the
vaccine
in question and want people first and
foremost to know that we have been
advised that there is no danger from the
vaccine they received
that's good news i think what they're
saying is that basically it's just
ineffective like because it was expired
people basically just the expired part
was like it was
thawed for too long is that the idea i
don't i don't know exactly
well maybe but the the reason i read the
story is
i don't like the idea that we do these
like in front of 7-eleven medical
you know uh procedures it's like there's
a reason why you go to a doctor and ask
for advice
they go to school for this they're not
perfect people they're regular people
but they specialize in certain fields
yeah you don't like their opinion you
can always get a second opinion
but when you show up to one of these
like this was a pop-up in times square
that was the former nfl experience
this is literally it and the employees
there couldn't
look at the expiration date which is on
the product i mean
that's just how can you people have
trust i i i i i'm timmy i think you're
on to something too you know like you're
saying you know
it's important to have a relationship
with your doctor and it's important to
consult your doctor and make a decision
like this and this is coming from a
canadian you know i think
americans there's a certain decadence to
the superiority of the american medical
system from
any other in the world and and
it's i think it's lost on a lot of
americans you know big pharma
and i'm not disagreeing with anything
you're saying about the opioid epidemic
is horrific
and there have been so many there have
been so many issues with big pharma and
i'm not like you know i've heard the
stories and i'm not discounting them and
that's important and fair
but there's also a level of personal
responsibility that comes into
taking medication you know and i'm not
blaming people who are addicted to
heroin for their addiction to heroin but
but i mean well i should say i'm not
blaming
what all i'm trying to say is big farm
big farm is important
big pharma cures cancer big pharma you
know
finds polio vaccines too you know
they're not just
pushing a sketchy rushed you know well
that was that was
salt right he gave it away for free
didn't he he did yeah
but it just means that he did not hold
that like there's something to be said
for a privatized
drug industry because the amount of r d
the amount of break like the
breakthroughs that come out of the
united states
are what keeps the the rest of the world
yeah i i i i think
there's something to be said you're
right weighing what you're taking but
not necessarily demonizing the people
just making whatever and trying to sell
it yeah yeah i think you know what i'm
going to walk by those statements say
big pharma is our friend um we should
never criticize them
ever in any way i just i'm kidding i
don't mean that i just mean that they
don't deserve all the flack
you know no they do they deserve to at
least be held accountable
and they haven't been because they've
been getting slaps on the wrist and just
small fines compared to their profits
for the horrible things that they did
yes they do some good things but but
when you allow
big companies to get away with such
horrendous treacherous
acts where people who are unsuspecting
people who are trusting people who
believe in the establishment get
punished the most for it
you need some ramifications where the
executive who made sure that
the hiv strain got out there because he
wanted to make a buck
that he he goes to jail not that his
company gets a slap on the wrist gets a
little bit of money he needs to be
personally held responsible for his
actions and none of that has happened
you know of course i think you don't
think pharmaceutical companies could be
like
limited liability companies are they
what is the law regarding
big pharma has no liability when it
comes to this vaccine so if you you take
it you get hurt
all the responsibility afterwards is on
you as an individual what about that's a
correct what about
other corruptions and there hasn't been
any
big ramifications with that entire
industry
that that have been significant and
that's why they keep doing it and unless
you hold them accountable they're going
to do another opioid epidemic because
they got away with it in the first place
a lot of this i think is also on the
insurance companies of course and we've
seen a complete
you know decimation of the whole health
insurance situation with the aca because
i don't know if you guys have ever
bought your insurance on
any of the um you know aca
exchanges but it's like every year you
buy a plan
and then at the end of and then you like
try and figure out what doctors take it
you try and figure out what your
deductible is which is usually
ridiculous
you can't actually ever get to a doctor
it takes a long time to get an
appointment and then the following year
it turns out your plan has been
discontinued and you have to buy
something else
and every time you have to go through a
whole qualification process
like i just i was trying to buy
insurance this year
and it turned out to be like they want
income verification
and i work for a canadian company and
i'm like i don't even have what you
want wow yeah that's weird yeah the
whole system and then they put my sons
and they were like oh this is connected
to your son's
you know state plan because he's on like
child health plus with new york state
which i'm happy about
but now they're trying to link that and
they're like i need income verification
for that and i'm like
no like just insure my kid i'm paying
you well uh
let's let's let's jump to the bad news i
guess
or bad news oh yeah it's a different
kind of bad news for all the people that
think you know what i don't
live in these cities i don't care what
new york does i don't care what
california does i've been saying that
i'm like hey look i live in the middle
of nowhere
well here you go everybody the blue
state exodus americans fled new york and
california for republican states of
arizona idaho and the sun belt to escape
lockdowns and skyrocketing crime
so the people who voted in these these
crooks and criminals and
the democrats who bring about failed
policies and all those who overlap
will now be coming to where you live and
voting for those exact same things
so you are going to vote the same yep
and i think this goes back to what i was
saying because i will stand by this i
think that the
liberals have a sense that they have a
moral high ground
i think they believe in their morality i
don't think uh i just i don't think so
i think they do i think some maybe i
think that's the ethos i mean i don't
know about
you know for example joy reid or whoever
else uh
in the media but individuals that i
speak to who are on the left
are pretty sure that their empathy and
compassion-based
approaches to you know politics and
whatever
are exactly right this is the moral
perspective to have
i i disagree i think they're paranoid
delusional psychopaths
who hold con uh uh different
paradoxical moral moral views that make
no sense such as
they do make no sense i'm not saying
they're more there's no moral framework
like
no it's not effective but no believe it
there's no
i i don't think i mean i don't think you
can say they believe things that
contradict each other because then one
contradicts the other
like when they come out and say stop
asian hate and we need to and end these
things
and then you point out that the specific
attack they're highlighting so so for
example they did a march to end white
nationalism
yes because a black man attacked an
asian guy that's correct how can you
have a moral framework
when they're like it's it's there was an
article that came
out shortly after that that defined um
you know a black person attacking an
asian person as white supremacy because
of
ingrained white supremacy that's that's
that's i'm imagining trying to build
i'm
that's what makes it a religion it's not
logical i i understand what you're
saying about
belief but i don't think belief is the
right word because if you show them a
picture of a
of a blue cube and say what color is
this and they say red
and then you you and then you say close
your eyes and open your eyes now what
color is it they say green
how do they believe it's both red and
green at the same time when it's blue
you see my point
i mean are there four lights i mean it's
like it's not it's not belief
it's like it's it's it's it's something
else it's zeletra it's blind
faith that whatever they're doing makes
sense even when it doesn't
they don't believe one thing they don't
believe that you should stop asian hate
when they cheer for the beating of andy
no
they correct they don't they don't they
don't want to end white nationalism they
think they do
i i don't i think or maybe even more
they feel they do
i the reason i disagree i i agree to a
certain extent
but if if the if the thing they believe
in changes every minute
how can you say they believe it because
i think they do
but how can they so it's like if you ask
them do you think
saying how can people have the kind of
cognitive dissonance that makes them
believe in a
complete moral fallacy no no how can you
say someone believes
that uh asians are oppressed when
literally a minute after they say it you
ask them again they'll say they're not
oppressed
so so clearly the second time they say
something totally different
contradictory to what they said before
they can't believe the first thing or
the second thing
or they're just not actually thinking
anything through with any kind of
framework
so there's no belief structure there
that's literally just my trust
you're my enemy and i think that there's
a righteousness and i think that there's
a feeling of moral superiority
i don't think it checks out i think it's
actually much more simple
they don't believe anything other than
you are the enemy and if you approach
them
and say anything that falls outside of
their cult they'll just say
no matter what it is i'll agree with it
if it means i'm opposed to you
right but how are we supposed to have a
dialogue with these people
you don't because they're half the cut
like aren't we pretty much like split it
was like 75 million voted for trump and
like
81 million voted for biden or something
like that most
mo how are we supposed to deal with this
i mean do you really think that we're
looking at a future where we're going to
have a
an america that's divided yes i mean we
already are yeah like we're looking at
can't we try and imagine a better future
than that well i think there's realism
and idealism we have
the story we literally pulled up is that
people are fleeing
states for other states what's happening
in a lot of ways if you look at like new
york during the pandemic is that the
wealthy people of means
flee to the suburbs and they flee to
reds red states now many of them may
actually start
and probably will start voting for
democrat policies but the people in
california who like
the their tribe and their strange moral
shifting sands will stay there gavin
newsom can violate all the lockdowns
can be found in the in the fancy
restaurant with no mask on and they
stand by him simply because
that's what they're supposed to do fauci
can change his answer every other day
and he did
and they'll stand by him because our
tribe is the right tribe
the divide is becoming so insane that
right now you there's no agreement on
what reality even is
no there's that's very peculiar you you
ask someone on the left no one even
knows what the what
men and women are anymore exactly and i
go to my friends
and i'll say i see a post on my facebook
from someone i've known from you know
when i was growing up in chicago and
they'll say look at this insurrection in
in dc and all that
and i'll talk to him and say i hear you
it was bad what are your what's your
opinion on the antifa blm riots and they
say what riots
right there literally fear of people in
every major city and even small towns
smashing up windows
and they're like i don't know what
you're talking about that's not true
that never happened stuff is still going
down in minneapolis i think
it is absolutely drive-by shootings
seattle but i think there was like there
have been like riots and stuff in
minneapolis recently
yeah portland yeah and just even coming
in i saw
like there's a bunch of demonstrations
in midtown manhattan and police are like
on twitter
stay away from the demonstration in
midtown han in my opinion what's
happening right now
is sort of what happened in orwell and i
think this is plan organized insanity
chaos where
the ruling elites get order out of chaos
and just like in 1984 they had people
admit that two plus two equals five
there's literally people arguing on
twitter that two plus two equals five
right now
because math is sexist and that's not
even a joke and and
i actually had your article that you
mentioned up ready to talk about this
before you even brought it up and this
was an article
that yahoo news published that was
titled white supremacy is the root of
all
race-related violence in the united
states and it says
in there quote so when a black person
attacks an
asian person the encounter is fueled
perhaps by racism
but very specifically by white supremacy
white supremacy does not require a white
person to perpetrate it
it's a cult it's insanity well that's it
like that's i'm thinking like it doesn't
there doesn't need to be
continuity in it right because like
people have this yearning to like be
part of something and people have this
hearing to be part of something bigger
than them and it doesn't always need to
have all the answers
in order to provide those services for
what they're looking for like
this is way more than a political
ideology this is like a lifestyle
it's just like a mindset it's a religion
a community it's a religion
absolutely it's serving all the purposes
and like if you talk to somebody
like and i'm not like if you talk to
somebody who's really religious
and you show them you know dinosaur
bones right
there are a million different answers
depending on who you talk to
that justify and recon reconcile the
religion with the dinosaur bones even if
it totally undermines what they're
saying
right it doesn't matter they were put
there to test us exactly that's common
and so you know and at least religion
comes by it honestly at least religion
is like i'm a religion
but this is different because it's a
political ideology and it has to do with
wielding power and it has to do with
policy and it affects all of us like at
least
religious people are chilling like
they're not bothering you
the catholic church certainly used to be
like that though i mean
fair enough but i mean quebec especially
right oh definitely yeah no of course
but i just mean like this is
a democrat like this is a major party
now now i'll put it this way i grew up
in an era when the moral
uh religious uh you know conservatives
were you know pushing religion and
pushing this ideology and
uh it wasn't this bad because i'll tell
you this
as much as i can say i believe in a
separation of church and state i don't
think we should have
religion in schools or whatever one of
the problems we have right now is that
the the cult of woke whatever whatever
it is the people are it doesn't even
matter what their moral framework is or
what their beliefs are they don't have
one
by the way it's shifting sands but it's
just whatever their tribe says is right
it's it's it's right no matter what
it is a religion and how do you separate
what they
what their religion is from government
and from schools the other thing i'll
mention is
at the very least the moral framework
from the the the judeo-christian values
that have created
you know a lot of this country they
provide for
innocence until guilt is proven they
provide for a lot of the rights that we
have
god-given rights now not i'm not a big
fat
fan of any specific religion or or
theism or anything like that
but i can certainly look at one religion
where they're like okay
you get a fifth amendment the other
group the other religion says
we don't care if you're guilty or not
we're gonna burn you at the stake that's
actually
the joke we make about the salem witch
trials if you know
what's the monty python thing if she
floats then she weighs the same as a
duck and
also a wood wait like it made no sense
they were condemning you without due
process
if she floats she's a witch and if she
drowns she's innocent well that was the
actual
that was the actual thing if she drowns
she's innocent
what they're doing now with cancer
culture they become religious moral
zealots
like without the enlightenment we never
get rid of slavery
another thing we should acknowledge here
is that the bible is currently being
written
through social media algorithms and i do
think social media algorithms are making
people go insane and that's another
aspect we really have to entertain here
because
ever since we had the onset of social
media we had
self-harm suicides depressions anxiety
panic attacks other mental disorders
drastically go up and i think you know
we're trying to understand
the the the madness it's madness it's
insanity it's people who are not well
off who
are off of their rocker who are saying
if a black person attacks an asian
person it's white people who are
responsible for this which is utterly
crazy
to even think about it's people arguing
two plus two equals five
literally these people you know are not
in right in the head they've been
institutionalized
they've been going along with what
society expects of them what is planned
by them by the elites going to school
going into their indoctrination camps
going in through watching the television
paying attention to social media and not
even getting a point of view
out of out of that control grid that is
shaping these minds to be where they are
right now where
there's there's you know people talking
about fat phobia being racist
there's toddlers twerking in new york
city a place where six people were shot
last night and the mayor right now
his major initiative is regulating
scooters let's let's let's talk about
where
come on those are really annoying i love
let's talk about where this ideology
ideology leads us the thing the one
thing though i would like to say is that
so all of this woke religion comes
after the decimation of mainstream
christianity and i think it shows us
that
society wants religion society wants a
religion and if we don't
actually embark upon the creation of
religion in
a in a reasonable way we're going to end
up with complete batshit madness well
let's let's let's talk about where where
we ended that anyway
we have the story from fox multi-state
shooting spree was racially motivated
suspect was targeting white men
gunman allegedly said i had to have him
about one of the shooting victims
what happens when you have a psychotic
and irresponsible
or corrupt let's get corrupt media
infrastructure
where many of these people know they're
lying how do i know they know they're
lying because i worked for some of these
companies
i've spoken with the hierarchies
companies who flat out said
this is what we do we just side with the
audience give them what they want to
hear
you end up with paranoid delusional
psychotic individuals
and you end up with people whose lives
are garbage
going on a shooting spree targeting
white people simply because he says
that all my life my problems were caused
by these white people their bullies
so he just had to go out and do it and
then
when you see black lives matter burning
down buildings and destroying cities the
media lies about it
when you see antifa engaging in a
year-long campaign of mass destruction
and riding
low-level terror across the country the
media lies about it
and then what do you get from your
federal government
you get u.s lays out plan to confront
white supremacist violence what
i read cnn and fox news okay i read all
these left-wing outlets and right-wing
outlets
and i couldn't tell you how many times
there's been literal white supremacist
violence
i mean i i couldn't tell you specific
instances i could i could i could name
tons of different instances where the
left is engaged in overt
political terroristic violence oh i get
it what's that reuters they have a
picture
of the capitol what else do you what
else do you have
that's it yeah i mean a lot of times too
these things that are
that are labeled as white supremacy
there's no evidence of white supremacy
and the only way that you can say that
they're that the left can claim that
they're white supremacist
is by going with this idea of
unconscious bias
so we don't have any evidence that says
you know chauvin was being white
supremacist when he killed george floyd
in minneapolis last year
but this is now touted as a white
supremacist thing the people who were
involved in the capital riot most of
them were what like bankrupt primarily
this is what we're seeing with i was
mentioning this this crazy guy who's
like screaming
rhonda sanders manning critical race
theory is is is fascism oh geez
they're conflating classical liberalism
with fascism on purpose
any authority that is that that can be
used as an example of fascism will be
even when it's not authority is not bad
it's not it's not inherently evil uh
exploitation of an author
of an authority position is a bad thing
but a cop issuing an arrest
no if you violate the social construct
the
the the agreements we have with one
another then you face the penalties of
that
that's the thing like if you re if you
read like the really like woke rags that
talk about this stuff
the way they define white supremacy is
like really innocuous elements of
western culture like being on time and
right like objective yeah like objective
thinking and objective reality
is considered to be white supremacy no
literally no but the thing that like
just
triggers me so much about this is like
growing up after 9 11
and like watching this happen with islam
where
where like wahhabi islam was conflated
with islam
and then that was used as a precursor to
do whatever like the pentagon and like
intelligence agencies
wanted to do wherever they wanted to do
it and we were all
freaked out and didn't know what we were
looking at and believed them
and trusted them and kind of gave them
carte blanche to do whatever
and this like just totally triggers me
because
it brings me right back to listening to
newscasts in 2002 2003
and i can just hear it but you've
switched out the terms
and i feel like we're careening toward
carte blanche on western culture
we we're being consent of the middle
east we're we're being gutted
of core classical liberal american
values
this this play from the bite
administration to target domestic
terrorism
right is that they're just going after
they're like we're going after militias
right
what they've started doing in the media
is they started saying if you are a
right-wing group that believes in
bearing arms and being a militia you're
white supremacist
even though it's like ridiculous many of
these guys just are like yay america
now the federal government is going to
start spying on these people and going
after them and bring the war on terror
to our soil
that's exactly what i was getting at and
we're going to end up with mass
surveillance of
americans we already had that and the
war on terror is literally turning
domestic uh right now as we're speaking
glenn greenwald wrote an article today
that is titled
the new domestic war on terror has
already begun even without the new laws
biden wants
and what you brought up about this
latest operation a multi-agency
operation by the u.s government
it's also going to be working very
closely with social media companies
and their main goal is to id prosecute
and to deter
white supremacy and militia members
uh and again those are extremely vague
terms who do you consider a militia who
do you consider a white supremacist
we've seen those terms
bastardized we see those terms almost
become meaningless because of how many
times it was used on absolute nonsense
and and did the government specify
exactly what groups
what specific individuals will be
targeted here
nope they're keeping it very vague which
means that they could use this big power
grab
to do whatever they want and that's
exactly what they did with 911 they used
this whole
war on terror objective to go after the
american people they set up the
infrastructure
they set up the jails they set up the
cameras they set up the gun pointed at
the american people
and now it looks like they're going to
be acting on it and it's it should
terrify people especially with
what the atf is doing as well and also
it makes you glad that mitch mcconnell
kept merrick garland out of the supreme
court because he's going to be out as
soon as biden's out but if he was in the
supreme court he'd be there for the rest
of his life
we uh that is absolutely 100 correct i
think we need
non-violent civil disobedience and mass
non-compliance what does that look like
that looks like people in conservative
areas not spending money on
companies that hate them that support
any of the stuff
so you're calling to use leftist tactics
against the left is it a leftist tactic
to be like
mass corporate boycotts that's i mean i
don't see any problem with that i think
i don't think it's a leftist tactic no i
think it's interesting because
we were looking at this with regard to
critical race theory too there was an
article in nbc today
about how um you know parents should not
you know parents groups are basically
funded by dark money and conservative
think tanks and that's why they're going
after school boards to try and get rid
of critical race theory in schools
and they're sort of decrying this and
it's like yeah
we're using your grassroots tactics now
that's what we're doing
yeah i don't think it's leftist though
uh because i don't think it has i don't
i don't think of it as an organized
effort i think it's quite literally just
don't buck a coca-cola i started i
jokingly bought rc
not that like the parent company for rc
is i didn't buy those
i did yeah why did you buy those
breaking the rules i just eat coke sorry
no you see this is the problem coke
literally has
woke indoctrination and you when you go
to the store you just don't care
and so what happens is we are passively
i bought rc cola
and i bought a small business like
uh pure cane sugar no high fructose corn
syrup
pops they're cute so there's also pepsi
over there to be honest
but this is the problem coke can do it
and conservatives
just don't care they don't care and
they're willing to keep throwing their
money
at people who hate them it's kind of
hard i mean
honestly i agree with you obviously i
totally agree with what you're saying
and that's fair you know you vote with
your dollar but
it's just exhausting to be so wound up
all the time
you know it's exhausting to have to
think about what
and like keep up with what like at one
point i wanted to boycott netflix i
forget what my like grievance was
at the time it was a couple years ago no
no it was way
way predicted big mouth
i don't remember they did they produced
some kind of problem like something that
i
figured was propaganda and decided i was
done with netflix and and it's just
exhausting
oh was it the cutest is that you didn't
no no no way before but
and like and you know you start kind of
like building up a
repertoire of companies that you're just
not dealing with anymore and at a
certain point you end up
just kind of hurting yourself
just just just giving up and giving in
that's exactly what happens yeah that's
exactly when
yes the fight against tyranny is
exhausting and i
i guess most people eventually just say
i'd rather not fight at all
please master just give me a piece of
cheese and i will do whatever you say
that's what's happening yeah we watched
our government
shut down and destroy small businesses
mass print money devaluing our own
savings
and then we were forced to shop at big
box stores and amazon
while our opinions were filtered through
the machine of social media with insane
garbled nonsense
i will say living in in brooklyn in a
heavily immigrant community
i was still able to shop at local
businesses that were owned by
families in the neighborhood yeah that's
a good thing the pandemic and i
appreciate that
what we're trying so a lot of people are
like tim why are you still on twitter
then uh look we're trying to leverage
the networks to the best of our
abilities to get people to go to
timcast.com to build the website
to hire people to build stuff there
basically i'll put it this way
it is the exodus we're not going to just
cut off our nose despite our face
we're going to say okay we will use what
we can of the system we have
but we're packing our bags and leaving
that's part of the process
that's why we're setting up more and
more at timcast.com that's why we're
doing our own original articles
because i'm trying to get away from the
broken system and build something
on our own it's not something you can do
overnight but we can get started
okay so to be fair maybe you don't stop
you don't start by boycotting literally
everything on the planet
but stick to it i cancelled my disney
plus because of the the
pr the the thanking of the xinjiang uh
paramilitary group that was has the
weaker muslims i'm like i'm not going to
support that
granted unfortunately to be completely
honest i paid for a year up front
so but i'm i'm uh uh i don't have
netflix
and i don't have hulu i'm just i'm done
like
hulu did something about cultural
appropriation and there's a period where
i was like i'm not going to boycott i
don't care about this i don't want to
get involved
and then i changed and i said look if
your company wants to get involved in
the culture war by all means go ahead
and do it i'm out
i don't want to play that game so i
bought jokingly rc cola but
rc's parent company i believe signed on
to the statement about georgia's voting
laws it's like it's really hard to get
away from
the thing with the voting laws is
infuriating because you have celebrities
coming out
and the you know full president coming
out saying that these are jim crow laws
and if you actually take a look at the
bills they
are merely rescinding the pandemic
era you know allowances to make voting
easier specifically due to pandemic
restrictions
so it's not that they're jim crow i mean
obviously they're not jim crow laws
and they're they're not limiting voting
in fact
in several of these cases they are
expanding early voting
they're just pulling the things that are
ripe for fraud
they're just taking more and more and uh
unfortunately for the right or whatever
you want to call it life and right it's
meaningless in a lot of ways the left
will use it as a tribal signifier is
just really good at this
and the right is really really bad at it
well it's because we've seeded culture
to the left
and that has to stop we have to i mean
it's like you were talking about you're
making your own culture
um you're making your own cultural
products the daily wire is doing that
yep
um the book that i'm writing is about
you know how to
make a conservative culture movement and
i have a lot of great
ideas on how to do that i'm actually
super excited about it but this is what
people need to be doing look at gina
carano you know she's out there just
like i don't need your
i don't need your mandalorian i can do
my own project
we need to get to the point where we can
be self-sustaining with our own versions
of
of products that work maybe the solution
is someone should start a cola company
that's not coke and they can call it
conservacola i don't know something dumb
and really obvious
and twitter can go create their own
nigeria absolutely
i understand the problem is that yeah
when you try to make your own twitter
networks we try to escape the system and
build your own companies they come after
you and shut you down
we started yeah we've totally seen that
we started a vlog cast castle
and the reason the way i explained to
people is it's very simple we got a
video where we're like skating in
in the garage skate park there's a
gadsden flag in the background that way
some young person who's watching the fun
skate video
with some you know pro bmxer or pro
skateboarder they'll see that
they'll recognize it and then when their
teacher lies to them and is teaching
critical race theory garbage and says
the gadsden flag is white supremacist
they'll say
that's not true i watch a guy on youtube
who's got that you're lying
that's what they did with pewdiepie when
the media kept trying to claim pewdiepie
was racist and all that
he had a legion of fans saying that's
not true you're lying about pewdiepie
i'm a fan
so we got to build culture we can't just
sit here and be like it's bad they did
this
we've got to do something else so you
know what i'm actually going to
go we've been playing this for a while
to do our own sodas we're gonna have our
own tim cassotis
you you call these these companies they
do formulas and
then uh they will make a specific flavor
and then send it to a
manufacturing plant super like they're
not very big corporations that do it
that's even better and then we're gonna
have our own soda and then i'll get a
little little
vending machine and we'll we'll make
luke's luke's old timey sasquarille how
does that sound loot
or butter beer luke's luke's old tiny
butter beer
there you go harry potter fan right i
was just in orlando so
uh
they have to put like crack in there or
something because it's good what is it
it's
it's this beer that's uh butterscotch
and just soda it's not really beer
there's no
most beers there's not fluoride there's
no alcohol or fluoride in there
i hope uh but it's just um yeah i i
it's my guilty thing that butterscotch
soda yeah
that it was good and the rides were fun
they were so fun
that was a normie i was a normie for a
little bit i had so much fun doing that
with my kid we got the wand and we did
the whole
yeah it was fun sorry
well i'm going off topic here yeah watch
um
you know people can do it's like buy
books from
uh writers michael knowles book came out
you've got andy noe's book unmasked
you've got michael malus's book you've
got uh jack bosobic's book buy those
books so that on amazon they hit the top
of the charts
tell like show people and another thing
too is like on youtube when they when
they thumbs down these videos and the
white house is forced to take down their
ranking system and comments
that makes a statement but you know it's
things like that
that's good there's got to be more to it
voting with your dollars is very
important
it's funny when you watch the youtube
videos of the white house press
conferences
and there's there's so many less viewers
than there were
like a year ago well two years ago even
you know
another aspect that's critically
important is voting with your attention
deciding what you will incentivize are
you going to turn on
netflix or you're going to turn on
independent media are you going to go
after and seek it
and seek information that of course is
going to be valuable no one said
personal responsibility was easy
personal responsibility is about
learning yourself the importance of
liberty of freedom of being reliable on
yourself and
and that journey is is an amazing one
you could you could live a journey where
you could
literally live in a pod eat the bugs be
a total slave of the establishment be
you know imprisoned by the algorithm in
your own head or you could
live a life of exploring discovering and
when you truly do put yourself on this
path
which starts with your ideas with you
just deciding to think about
good beautiful positive things that you
could have for yourself when you put
yourself on this pathway
life is so much more adventurous it's so
much more awesome it's so much more
amazing yes it's easy
to sit on your butt be a couch potato
eat your gmo monsanto
corn down your pie hole you could do
that all you want you know it's just
that easy because it makes you depressed
does anybody does anybody watch zombie
movies just go man i wish i was the
zombie
yeah that's that's apparently what's
happening right now with so many people
in these cities wow
it's not easy it's institutionalized
it's what people are expected
to do and when they are in there they're
miserable and when they're miserable
when they're depressed
when they have anxiety then they need to
buy more useless crap to fill the empty
void within themselves and that's why i
think there's been such a huge agenda
to break up the family unit to make sure
that people are individualized to make
sure that they're going to be
easily uh prey for the larger corporate
establishment once you break up the
family unit
which is a natural grouping right once
you break that up
you can siphon individuals into separate
identity groups
and then you can work on equity between
groups and then that's how we have
marxist infiltration of american
democracy exactly and that's why a lot
of marxist organizations even blm
officially called for breaking up the
family unit because it's integral
to let their brainwashing mouth get
through to individuals
exactly this is how you do it first you
make it so that you don't have any idea
who you can trust
and that's why in poland they attacked
the churches the churches were very
instrumental
with fighting back against communism
which my family was a part of doing
and and the the family unit i think a
lot of people are haven't misconstrued
yes there's there's a lot of bad things
but
it's not like they weren't there before
we're just realizing that
this exists the veil is unraveling and
what it is
it's providing an opportunity for people
to actually see the world for what it is
and not become
victim of the larger traps laid out in
front of them and i think this is an
amazing thing that's happening
and i think people are finally deciding
waking up and making the decisions that
are right for themselves
and and if they're not i mean personal
responsibility means you're responsible
for yourself and i think we need to
teach people that
more and incentivize make people
understand that at the end of the day
you're responsible for yourself and
nobody else is and no one's going to
come to help you
no one's going to go out of their way to
to to
make sure you're in a good position
unless you do it for yourself
let's go to super chats my friends if
you haven't already
smash that like button it really does
help subscribe to this channel
and go to timcast.com become a member i
know everybody's super excited i
mentioned this yesterday i was like we
do have a new editor-in-chief coming in
you're all big fans
she's gonna do a great job but i'm not
gonna say who it is everybody
immediately tweeted at cassandra they're
like we know it's you we know you're
friends with him we know this is going
to be you doing this
cassandra does a really great job
writing legit news
the left hates her because of her
opinions on twitter i don't care when
you look at the story she actually
writes they're fleshed out
they're fact-based they're sighted she
does a great job we're going to be
bringing out a bunch of other reporters
and it's going to be fantastic and
everyone's going to serve as a sort of a
check and a balance on each other but we
are going to have
a fact checker not even in this building
that we're going to be hiring
who's going to be in a different
building that way when we write
something
we then they then see the articles
published and they'll go through it and
fact check it
that's what newsroom's supposed to do
she'll have an independent fact checker
challenging what your own staff are
writing so you can complain all day and
night about the individuals working here
but we're gonna have a separate unit
that does fact checking as well
it's going to be fantastic and it's
because you guys are members at
timcast.com were able to do this
my favorite is how they're desperate to
lie someone someone tweeted that
i was trying to sell my house to get a
loan or like get a home loan to pay for
it
not true this is all coming because
people started to become members and now
we have the capital
to do it we don't need big fat you know
fat cat silicon valley or new york
investment firms now we're totally
independent baby
and we're going to be able to hire great
people who do great work and it's going
to be awesome thanks to you so again
smash that like button
let's read some of these super chats we
got
civil stick says breaking 1986 chernobyl
school with physics lab to blame for
radioactive fallout to say anything else
is to deny science
yeah as we know that when chernobyl
happened they the soviet union was lying
about it and then we were like yo
there's like radioactive particles
everywhere something's happening yeah
but they lied
they're radioactive spiders they're wait
wait wait
right now in in chernobyl right now
there are spiders
yeah they're spiders if you want to be
spider-man you're saying i should
i think that's a good start you'll just
get sick if they bite you don't don't do
that the spiders have different um the
spiders that all have specific patterns
have different patterns after chernobyl
oh yeah whoa
crazy that's creepy man elated echo says
can't wait for cassandra very excited
screw the jerk that's dragging her we
want her here love you all
so if you actually read her articles
they're like really straightforward
you know sometimes she'll write
something where it's like alex you know
like
you know some hyperbole in it but that's
whatever but the stuff she's written for
the site so far on like day one
it's all just like very straightforward
quotes explaining what's happening and
it's really good work
so they don't like it and that's
probably why she's really feisty on
twitter
but you know that's too bad for them all
right jonathan galterini says luke cult
cult cult let's go lol
lookuncensored.com the physicality
channel says these streams aren't live
this is the craziest conspiracy theory
it's my favorite i love it
yeah they think the streams aren't live
for some reason i don't know how can we
prove it
i don't know i'm like i'm reading super
chats
i don't know it's pretty complex
yeah it's like if someone how do you how
do you not i don't know man people are
people are crazy
rampton says i'm buying a we are change
shirt because luke's back
well thank you i appreciate that that's
right
all right vladis mosley says hey tim i
think youtube is playing games with your
notifications today is the first time
since i've been tuning in when i didn't
get an alert that's right
youtube is uh uh absolutely doing that
and there's nothing
there's what can you do i don't think
youtube owes me promotion
but i'll tell you this so long as they
do promote my content i'll be like go to
timcast.com and become a member
because once we get to that point where
we're self-sustaining where people are
sharing the articles and sharing the
videos
uh we're not going to need youtube for
anything we need to build our own
system and uh you know we're working on
a bunch of open source projects to help
expand the idea of independent ownership
of content and fight back against the
the conglomerate
the conglomeration or whatever
conglomeratization
of of independent media the takeover by
the corporations want to shut down
independent voices
we've got to build we've got to resist
and that's what we're doing
all right so uh
zone dnb says congrats on your newsroom
tim but how do you plan on ensuring it
stays neutral
twitter was the pro free speech platform
until it wasn't
we don't i'm sure it's only a matter of
time until
you know it's like 20 years and i'm like
you know i started this to challenge the
system and no i look in the mirror and i
am the system it happens
that's why we just need you know maybe
one thing we can do is just uh
at a certain point when the company gets
too big we launch another startup and
give people an independent newsroom
it's hard it really is i don't know the
biggest concern i have and the reason
why we're launching all of this is
because
look i can be a guy on youtube and talk
about what i talk about but what happens
after i i'm like i'm old and i'm
retiring
there's got to be something that lives
on beyond me at the very least we can
plant the seeds of this culture and hope
it
remains true and expands maybe there's
something we can do
with like corporate by-laws and
restrictions or something we'll figure
it out
jimmy quinto says i got my doge shirt
thanks it's a great shirt isn't it that
no no joe go to timgeous.com go to the
store and we got a bunch of silly shirts
we got the diamond hands gorilla he's
he hasn't sold his amc stock so of
course he's rich then we got the doge
shirt which is they're all like this
joke of like the i am a guerrilla thing
but check them out
all right the weary says i am a simple
man
i see luke i hit like wondering if the
beanie squad has looked into
cher tanzania at all mike tyson did a
charity fight for them
john st julian on youtube right on
i think people are all screaming that
they love luke because they're worried
to leave
they better be rizzle says gun owners of
america has pre-written comments for the
atf comment section on proposed rules
for renaming
frames and receivers and pistol braces
ban it's very
important contact guns and gadgets asap
you should definitely check into that i
will look into that as well
taz wright says people often talk about
the problems yet don't mention solutions
you want things to change form your own
community like
an intention intentional community be
the be the change
be the change luke i heard that
somewhere yeah but in today's video i
was actually talking about the the most
important currency that you could have
during
turbulent times and the most important
one is social currency
the people around you your neighbors
your family work on
your relations because they're also
going to be critical when things break
down and
they're they're already breaking down
all right we got evil zombie hamster
says
seattle city council candidate ubaxx
guard here pled
down from a felony for a bomb threat on
a school bus seattle democrats are
backing her
i don't live in seattle but i live in
washington and seattle's politics runs
our state
boy yeah we probably know we broke that
story the other day it's
crazy crazy it's crazy i don't think
people should live in these places i
don't think anyone should vote for that
person
yeah but they're gonna probably they're
going to so what happens when you have a
cult and government called the children
cowards as they
fled out the back at the back of the bus
you seven-year-olds you're cowards
you're all cowards
wow man
wolfrick wolf freak says security and
cali make 18
an hour trust me i was one of them until
last year when i moved to texas to flee
the koof oh there you go
all right first thessalonians says luke
i saw the grey state trailer and a video
of we are chain's reaction to the
trailer
claps and whistles and whoops how well
did you know david crowley
would utilize ever consider making a
movie based on david's concept trailer
um the movie uh the trailer the story
behind it has been absolutely crazy i i
met
uh i met that individual i think a
number of three times
i was around a lot of his uh friends
um and it's a tragic crazy situation of
what happened there
right on it e.c morgan says leftist
cities need to collapse like an atlas
shrugged
great to see you back luke missed you in
the show and now do the federal reserve
yeah we've been ragging on the federal
government quite a bit they deserve it
they're bad ward spo says good call on
cassandra tim she's a good human from my
perspective
as a person that hires people i think it
will be lovely
i think it will be a lovely relationship
my best i've known cassandra for like uh
a decade you've known a lot for a really
long time as well uh around occupy wall
street yeah yeah yeah so it's been a
while 10 years
yeah and uh i think this was like i
think
that's why everybody guessed that i was
hiring cassandra because it's fairly
obvious we've known it for so long and
you know but uh we're gonna have a great
team we've got a couple other people
they're all fair like cassandra is
definitely on twitter she's feisty
bombastic
but the other people we're hiring are
like no offense to them rather boring
like regular journalists and reporters
who write good work
and so you know there you go we'll we'll
have our uh
our rage from the left they can say
whatever they want i don't care
arceon says tim have you been to every
country in the world yet i ask this as
someone who feels left behind in life i
am desperate to travel
and how many people do you know that
have i do not know anyone that has been
to every single country
i have been to i think 30. luke you've
probably been way more than i
lost count uh but i love you you've
probably been to like more than half
yeah i was travel hacking and right
before kovid i was so happy and then
covet hit and i was stuck in
new york city which wasn't the place to
be during covid
will c says tim i no longer get
notifications when you go live
over the last two weeks i've had to
search my subscriptions to find the live
chat
keep it up that's right if you're
listening right now and you want to make
sure you never miss an episode
subscribe hit the notification bell that
still might not be enough but i'll tell
you this one of the most powerful things
you can do is take the url to the show
and just
share it on all social media and i think
you can always go to youtube.com
tim cast irl slash live but of course
with the new site rolls out we i don't
know exactly
when and when when it will be launching
this specific feature
we're planning on just having the live
run on the website as well we're trying
to use these networks
and you know have our exodus so long as
they drive massive amounts of traffic
we want to make sure we can guide people
to our platforms as well
so we'll use youtube to the best of our
abilities but yeah we'll have all the
stuff on the website
because sooner or later they're gonna
they're gonna just nuke us off youtube
william carlos says so i see you're
accepting bribes now tim great
please check out a pitch that i sent to
your pitches email i'd love to hear back
from you guys beluga whale
bribes in the form of super chats if you
super chat
i try to read as many as i can sometimes
people get their uh
their youtube chat red clef the misfit
says hey gang do you see the content cop
video on taylor loren's
with you with uh the youtuber boss wiki
did
professional thorough take down turns
out leftist women don't protect each
other either
interesting i didn't know that i watched
the video it was actually pretty uh
pretty good really yeah well there you
go
all right let's see
the licensed guru says good choice for
today's panel they should be on more
often
and missed hearing luke's opinion
welcome back thanks for having me let's
see uh
samuel uh leliak says where's the
coverage
by tim of the censoring of brett
weinstein's video
fda compliances in 500k u.s covid uh if
you'd like to see that
look they deleted brett weinstein's
video so we did a segment on timcast.com
it is yes for members only we're trying
we're trying to figure it out i don't
like putting things behind a paywall
when it's like extremely important
the website you know we'll we'll get to
the
the new iteration of it we're going to
have these very important things be
readily available and shareable and all
that stuff absolutely
we just need to get the framework
rolling but um if we did a video talking
about what
reinstein was talking about on youtube
they'd nuke us in two seconds this is a
very serious problem
what do we do if i come out and start a
video and i say hey guys here's the
thing that happened
there's a minute delay on youtube they
would nuke us before you even heard what
we said
often people are like whoa i don't even
get it they just got shut down yes
because youtube is watching
and they've been us so go to timcast.com
the conversation
it's the last one we did just the other
day it's in the members only section
scroll down you'll see a picture of luke
wearing a shirt
that says make america florida and
that's where you know you'll have found
it yeah the video
yesterday that we did is very important
and uh
definitely worth the watch wait you
really have a t-shirt that's make
america florida i mean i got demonetized
by youtube so i just started a t-shirt
company
and i started to make ridiculous
t-shirts and one of them is that t-shirt
i'll make you one but uh i i have my
t-shirt store is available on
thebestpoliticalshorts.com but i'll
but i'll give you one and that's been
one of the things i wrote an article
earlier this year that was uh like i
think it was called florida as a
paradise of freedom
it is it has been i just came from there
and it was absolutely amazing
jeff tanda says tim you shouldn't make
fun of colbert for being a contrarian
and give a halfway to the answer to an
issue since you do it all the time
while calling a hypothesis a conspiracy
keep up the good work though
i i'm so i'm sorry well i i certainly am
one to be able to take criticism
colbert obviously lying all the time and
me being skeptical are very different
things
like when colbert comes out and lies
about trump he's lying
when colbert comes out and says even in
the face
of like overwhelming evidence and and
even the mainstream media not coming
around saying lab leak
makes the most sense even with fauci now
saying he's not entirely convinced covet
is is natural colbert still tries
maintaining that lie well there's all
these bats here
there's a big difference okay yeah and
cold bear is not a contrarian he repeats
the same talking points as almost every
single late night tv show host which is
in unison always regurgitating
the same talking points all right
i am insanity says been following and
watching since 2015
going to ask for a shout out to my news
channel the n sane report
daily news with a psychotic twist and no
cursing i may be insane but i'm not
crazy
there you go julie simone says first
things first
welcome back luke great guests and
discussion per usual
as a farm d what's happening in sf is
sad for the patients
employees and city i lived there 2013
and 2020 and just left for florida
make america florida yeah there you go
mm-hmm
i got to get i gotta get some of those
shirts we gotta we gotta go here we
should we should go to florida too
no come on why not let's all go it's hot
and humid it's kind of awesome though
you get one month you get
you get january and may maybe february
january tim cast irl from miami florida
i can't do it bitcoin conference is
probably going to call it the
the winter studio yeah seriously the
winter white house you could be
snowbirds
yeah that sounds a lot better than the
shoveling snow off of my roof
like i have to off of my rv roof i live
in an rv cold water
shovel cold water says the magazine
popular mechanics had articles on how
two plus two is not always four
and the mechanics of pulling down a
statue i haven't renewed the magazine in
years and they keep sending it to me
so what's happening with the two plus
two equals five thing
is that they're using semantic arguments
to confuse you and make you
unable to do math so when we're talking
about just basic
integers and arithmetic whatever you
have two apples you have two apples you
got four apples
that's it what they do is they use like
semantic arguments like this
all right luke if you if if you have two
apples in your left hand and two apples
in your right hand and you put them
together
how many apples do you have five
twitter verse told me you still only
have two apples in each hand
yeah it's like it's it's ridiculous if
you have one apple and you take one away
look if you have two apples and you take
two take one away how many apples do you
have
i don't know two i guess
because just tell me what to say listen
listen
if you have two apples and you take one
away
it's not two minus one they're using
semantic arguments oh right because
i have two apples and i'm gonna took it
i'm still holding two apples
that's why two minus one equals two so
clever
they do this thing where they're like if
you have 2.4
and and and round and and round it
you'll get two
but if you have two plus four plus two
plus four you'll get four point eight
which rounds up to five
it's uh it's how you destroy reality and
then tell people what to think
yeah this is this is what happens to
with gender right we tell little kids
not to trust their instincts
makes everybody crazy and not to trust
their own bodies and then everyone's
insane
mm-hmm oh i can't read this it's in
polish
it's for luke i can't i can't see any
screens in front of me
it says deject luke
za power okay
and nightmare nightmare okay what did
what did he say i have no clue what
you're saying i said that in perfect
politics
yeah okay i i was it was it was
articulated perfectly luke just doesn't
actually speak polish
all right the throne says hey guys love
the talk about this ideology being a new
secularist religion that people are
blindly following despite conflicting
views
a name you could use for this religion
is statism and it's required for
socialism
yeah actually status it's just whatever
the establishment says they're like yes
yeah 100 you should wear two masks yes
don't wear two masks yes you should wear
two masks brick and mortar
guy yes that's all they're doing
fauci it's it's almost like fouch is
playing simon says and he's laughing
i wonder if like after every interview
he does he goes i just told him do the
exact opposite they're doing it it's
hilarious
and they're all laughing like
high-fiving each other i can't believe
they're falling for this
all right mrs
awesome says tim i completely agree with
boycotting companies that go against
interests
and you are also correct that people
cave to the fomo which is going against
their interest
people need to show their force by not
caving what we need
it's really simple we need more cultural
stuff
when people are on twitter and there's a
viral trend where they're like dude the
new episode of you know
like uh i don't know what is what's a
popular show like
big bang theory big bang theory yeah
conservatives need their own version of
that dude did you see that movie from
the daily wire it's so great you know
run hide fight yeah did you see that
no i don't i didn't see it either did
you see it no yeah nobody saw it
no i know a lot of people who did they
said it was pretty good it's going great
they're just well that's that's that's
the point it's not it's
they need more one movie isn't enough
for everybody to watch and then like you
go
we need a good series there needs to be
a viral hit if daley wire can put out
something that's like on par with the
virality of game of thrones
it's over then everyone's going to be
watching daily wire
so that's the thing like i feel like
there's a reason why that hasn't
happened yet i mean
i don't think and it sucks to say it but
i don't think that there's exactly an
even distribution
of creatives on the right and the left
i think that there's a certain kind of
person that tends obviously this is just
speaking generally
tends to lean left and there's a certain
kind of person that tends to lean right
and
they don't seem the person who seems who
tends to lean right doesn't seem to be
the same person that's the creative
i think that there's a reason why they
they kind of like fall on different
parts of a chart i wonder that that i
wonder if that's true or
if perhaps the institutions and the
gatekeepers that hold the keys to the
kingdom of culture and
art are so left-leaning that it's hard
to make any headway
if you i mean i went to art school and
people who might have had conservative
views did not ever speak them
playwrights that i know who are
conservative they don't
they don't talk about that they just you
know they try and like
slip in their stuff underneath so that
no one notices that they're saying what
they're what they think
maybe they should right well that's
that's one they ought to stand up
that's one thing that i think will
change the paradigm is that it's
becoming like so
militant you know these institutions
were always liberal but liberal had a
different meaning i mean liberal was
totally unthreatening and had no teeth
and it was just kind of this like
free flow mentality but it's
it's totally changed from that it's
become totally puritanical which
now is incompatible with art and
creating
and i definitely think that you're right
and i think that it's it's just changed
form and it's going to push a lot of
creatives who aren't necessarily
conservative but just aren't like that
away and into the arms of conservatives
or just people who aren't puritanical
we're going to be funding sitcoms and
films and comics
and the goal is just to not have it be
political and that's
the right move it's we're going to it's
going to have like undercurrents you
know what i mean there's going to be
certain things about like being a hero
saving people having personal
responsibility and stuff like that
but it's not going to be overt like you
know trump as superman fighting
you know communists or something art
doesn't have to be political
yeah it it it will i it will
it will have ideology ideology in it uh
it just won't be overt
it'll be like here's a hero he's a hero
because he believes these things
and that's it well once you tap into old
stories and once you tap into like
the river of human knowledge it's not
about ideology it's about telling
classic human stories
yeah all right jay schartzer says
thank god luke is back my throat was
getting sore from all the puking
that's right no luke rebuke callum escue
says first off it's great to see luke
again i just graduated from an arts high
school in the bay area
we have been force-fed marxism and ct
since eighth grade
i've been watching y'all since the kyle
rittenhouse incident thanks for keeping
me
sane during that we try man but uh it
takes each and every one of you to
share like people are saying like oh i'm
not getting notifications anymore
out of sight out of mind they want to
make sure you don't see it but if they
ban it outright when it's big it creates
a huge uproar so they got to do it very
very slowly
and i'm aware of that so i'm launching a
website we're bringing people on and
we're going to try and fight back
it's uh it's which it's it's what we got
to do but we need each and every one of
you to smash the like button
share the show and help spread the word
at the very least man all right
ski man from toronto says hey tim cass
gang great reset is for real
g7 leaders voted unanimously on minimum
15
global corporate tax rate lock us down
force our money to big corporations
tax them to hell on their new revenue
bailouts and more
they're not even trying to hide it they
use the same kind of generic talking
points of building back better
in their official g7 you know
announcement
man all right let's see we got one uh
someone mentioned a good book
where are we at where did it go which is
here we go
aka kamara says tim my guy you got to
read the righteous mind by jonathan
height
the difference between liberals and
conservatives is based on differences of
moral in
uh intuitions not based on logical
versus illogical that's correct
it's called the moral foundations and
there's actually i i think the book may
have only had five they've since added a
sixth
liberty foundation um i always try to
name them off to my head it's um
it's care fairness loyalty purity
purity isn't that sanctity or is it
purely the same thing
and authority and liberty did i say
liberty
i don't know there's six and here's my
here's my favorite first liberals only
have two moral foundations care and
fairness they don't care for authority
loyalty purity or liberty conservatives
have an equal distribution of all moral
foundations
the best one libertarians only have one
liberty they don't care about you they
don't want to be fair to you
they have no loyalty to you they care
they absolutely hate authority
there's no purity it's just let me do
what i want leave me alone
hey i'll take it if they're not
bothering me i don't care
but i guess there are problems in that
okay jonathan
kelly says i am suffering some uh from
same nerve damage as your friend i don't
know what to do
doc's included specialists don't have
much to tell me i'm in terrible awful
pain all day and all night long
head to toe man sorry to hear it uh yeah
a friend of mine's got nerve damage in
his arms and legs
so he can't you know play music or
skateboard anymore and uh
i've been talking about it and he said
just one day a few days after you know
getting vaccinated he started to feel
pain
and they said they think that his his
immune system went into overdrive and
attacked his nerves
yeah at least people should register
with fares uh if they do have
complications if they have any problems
they should report on it
uh so at least people know the the real
numbers out there because
they're already pretty staggering all
right alternative jk
says when it comes to sf you should look
at their current da chesaboden
he was raised by bernadine dorn and bill
ayers wow really
members of the radical left-wing weather
underground movement by the way got
luke's normalized critical thinking
shirt with good feedback
yeah no he his parents were really close
with weather underground and he was
literally raised by them that's not
checks out because his parents were in
prison and yeah so he was raised by
triers
was like his godfather something like
that you know his parents are still in
prison i think
i don't know what i do find like really
funny about this is that
you know 40 50 years ago you had these
ideologues who were like zealots for
their cause
and they they write all these things
about how this is the right way to do
things
and now it's a total like mess and it's
chaotic and everything's failing and
crime skyrocketing proving
their corrupt moral ideology was broken
from the get-go and now that's being
implemented everything's just burning to
the ground so congratulations on that
there was uh someone who was with the
weather underground who was uh
coordinating the funding for black lives
matter as well
that sounds right yeah yeah
willie boy p says tim can't hide his
bald head in the florida heat without
having a stroke that's exactly it i
can't wear a beanie in florida what am i
supposed to do
oh geez i lived in florida fedora the
fedora that's it
in uh in january and february we were
actually able to go out and skate and it
was comfortable
but nobody went outside unless they were
on the beach
yeah it's different i mean i was out
there people are
partying drinking going to restaurants
having fun it's
it's it's i love it there it's fun in
florida yeah alexander scarpecci says
tim cass news should bring ivory hecker
from fox 26 in houston i hear she is
looking for work
that is the woman who secretly filmed
her bosses at her local news outlet and
project veritas
is exposing what they were doing i guess
the only issue
is i'm sure project veritas is going to
fire her up is going to hire her
first so uh that seems
she seems like a perfect fit for veritas
her face is out there now though so i
don't know
angry goose says first time super chat
i'm a trucker and i love listening to
y'all chat every day it really helps
pass the time keep it the great work
hey man really appreciate it timeless
ninja says i need a trump superhero
comic tim
okay to be fair we probably will do that
because it'll be a hilarious saturday
already a manga about trump
well there's like a joke one it's called
um my hero magadina
yeah yeah and i don't know if you guys
are if you guys know anything about my
hero academia but there's a
superhero named almight and he's like
super ripped and blonde and like strong
so they make trump look like that i
really love the political cartoons about
trump
where he's ripped ben yeah ben garrison
oh my gosh
like whenever there's trump he's like
all i'm like dude the guy's back
he's out of shape he eats mcdonald's
yeah i know
but i love in their version of like the
you know he's like uh-huh and he's like
all chiseled in the v-shaped torso
yeah yeah serve mcdonald's to like the
winners of the nba championship one year
yeah or like some college team they love
this team the media ragged on them
but they were all like this is awesome
like a big mac script i don't i don't
like mcdonald's i'm not gonna have
the top three most hilarious trump
moments of his
presidency literally serving donald's on
a silver platter
yeah i know it's amazing uh when he when
he said only rosie o'donnell
when megan kelly was like you called
women fat pigs and he's like only rosie
o'donnell
there's the mcdonald's thing and then
there's kung flu which
was like i just was like oh jeez this
wow it was yeah heck of a president kind
of hysterically all right everybody if
you haven't already smash that like
button subscribe
share the show and go to timcast.com
because we have a bonus segment coming
up usually goes up around 11 p.m or so
you can follow us on facebook and
instagram cast irl where you can share
our videos and like them
because we're just trying to leverage
the existing networks so that we can
start moving
to timcast.com i want to make
timcast.com like a big
massive network i wanted to be a
multi-billion dollar media conglomerate
that believes in principles and you know
classical liberal values and things like
that
that's what we're working on maybe in
five years
ten years we'll be closer and closer and
closer so that's the plan
man you can follow me personally at tim
cast across the board this show is live
monday through friday at 8pm
uh do you guys want to shout anything
out that uh your social media or
where they can find you at emmajoenyc on
twitter
you can if you really start digging
you'll find my instagram but
that's not for work uh you can find me
every day at thepostmillennial.com and
on twitter at libby emmons
and we are change.org is the website top
right hand corner just sign up on that
email list it costs you nothing it's
free and
i send you premium videos on there my
main youtube channel is we
are change hope to see you there you
guys may follow me on twitter at
sourpatchlids
we will see all of you in the bonus
episode where we say all the things
youtube doesn't allow us to say
including swear words
that'll be at timcast.com so thanks for
hanging out we'll see you there
you